Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich muss mal kurz was trinken.
Ich bin doch nicht vor all zu langer Zeit aufgewacht.
Was, im Discord? Ach ja, das hab ich gesehen. Ich wollte ja eigentlich gestern Abend drauf antworten, aber ich hab's dann, ja, frag mich nicht.
Ich hab's gesehen, ich hab's gesehen, ja, können wir machen.
Ich kann auch eine Runde schwätzen in die Tage.
Muss mir erzählen, was die Inder soll treiben.
So, du bist dann über zwei Stunden wach. Das bedeutet seit 7.30 Uhr am Sonntag. Naja, kann man machen.
White people happy.
Perfektes Timing. Exzellent.
Ja, natürlich, was sonst, wer hätte daran gezweifelt, dass das heut kommt.
Bist du seit sechs Stunden wach, hau mir das dann auf und lasst mich ein paar einrichten.
Sechs Stunden, das bedeutet seit 3.30 Uhr. MonkaS. Ach so, seit 6 Uhr.
Okay, das macht einen Unterschied, ob sechs oder 3.30 Uhr.
Aber trotzdem.
Sechs Uhr Sonntags ist ein bisschen früh. Muss ich normalerweise aufstehen, wenn kein Homeoffice ist.
5.45 Uhr steh ich normalerweise auf, wenn ich nach Frankfurt muss, ohne Homeoffice.
Und ich mach das auch nur aus dem Grund, dass ich 15.30 Uhr ungefähr wieder abhauen kann.
Ich hab mal vor, ja ist schon ein bisschen her, aber ihr wisst ja, ich arbeite nur 4 Tage für die Woche
und ich hab mal vor 4. ó 4. Odita.
Ich trinke schnell ein bisschen ab.
Lass dichPhone notre immer wieder kassieren.
Stehe én vor, teknische shouting.
Hallo.
Aber ihr wisst ja ich arbeite nur vier tage die woche und ich habe mal vor von einem halben jahr oder so
Da alles bei uns so so technik probleme gab da war ich mal fünf tage am stück da ich sage euch leute ich weiß gar
Nicht wie ich das früher gemacht habe fünf tage am stück
Ich kann mir das überhaupt noch mal vorstellen fünf tage am stück 5 vor 45 aufstehen das ist so extrem anstrengend
Ich meine vier tage 5 vor 45 aufstehen ist auch anstrengend aber nicht so schlimm
Am besten ist natürlich vier tage aufstehen und dann um 7.30 weil man homeoffice machen kann das ist natürlich noch besser
Deswegen hoffe ich ja dass diese ganze corona homeoffice geschichte noch ein bisschen hält
Also wenn es nach mir geht ja ich bräuchte nicht die negativen auswirkungen von corona aber corona kann ruhig da bleiben
Dass man weiterhin dauerhaft homeoffice machen kann zumal man ja auch sieht der graben funktioniert
Also nach jetzt den zwei naja nicht das stimmt nicht wirklich eins haben was auch immer eineinhalb jahren ja
Nach einem jahr auch nicht ganz ich runde mal auf nach eineinhalb jahren dauer homeoffice
Also bei den unternehmen wo das nicht funktioniert die gibt es wahrscheinlich schon nicht mehr
Und dort wo das funktioniert kann man das auch weitermachen
Wann hast du frei ist montags montags der grund warum ich montags frei habe ist ganz einfach
Ein grund war also hat verschiedene gründe aber es ist eigentlich ganz ganz easy nachvollziehbar freitag
Freitag ist eh nicht mehr viel los ja also freitag sind die leute eh schon gut drauf entspannt weil es wochenende bald anfängt
Und freitag ist jetzt auch in der regel nicht so der tag wo die leute immer panik machen dass irgendwas passieren muss ok gut
Also freitag ist eh schon mal der entspannendste tag
Montag sind die leute immer noch krass motiviert und machen voll attacke bei allem und sind auch nervig
Dazu kommt dass ich ja am montag auch ein paar sachen ab und zu klären will oder zumindest war das der ursprüngliche plan
Für youtube twitch und seit gut damals hatte ich noch kein twitch aber
Sagen wir mal youtube und und sachen und da ist es natürlich gut wenn die leute mit denen man was klären will
halt
Noch motiviert sind ja
Muss fünf tage um 4 uhr 30 aufstehen ist ja noch schlimmer
Ich mein 5 uhr 45 kommt mir schon sehr früh vor
Aber 4 uhr 30 ist noch heftiger
Aber ich glaube es ist noch ein bisschen zu spät
Aber das ist noch ein bisschen zu spät
Was ist denn der erwartungswert ist das also ist das das was die leute denken das passiert oder das was was wirklich passiert
Dass die leute so viel weniger daheim machen
weiß ich nicht. Es ist wieder so das Problem, also das kann, sagen wir mal so, ich könnte
mir tatsächlich vorstellen, wenn du den kompletten Durchschnitt, sagen wir mal, über die gesamte
Bevölkerung nimmst, dass es tatsächlich so ist. Aber man muss ja auch mal sagen, da
ein kompletter Durchschnitt in dem Punkt, weiß ich nicht, wie sinnvoll das ist. Man
muss einfach gucken, für wen funktioniert das, für wen funktioniert das nicht. Und
vor allem, was ja viele Leute immer noch nicht gebacken bekommen haben, ist, sich einmal
einen gescheiten Homeoffice-Arbeitsplatz einzurichten. Wenn ich das dann teilweise sehe, ich weiß
nicht, ob das wirklich so ist, aber es gibt ja die ein oder anderen Fernsehberichte und
sonst was dazu. Wenn ich dann sehe, dass die Leute am Küchentisch mit dem Laptop hocken,
kein Stuhl mit Armstütze, Armlehne, die Kinder dabei rumrennen, das Telefon klingelt, der
Nachbar klingelt, DHL klingelt, 30 Millionen Leute anrufen. Ja, dann ist ja kein Wunder,
dass die Leute nix arbeiten können. Die Leute müssen das ordentlich machen, die brauchen
einen ordentlichen Arbeitsplatz. Das heißt, ordentlichen Schreibtisch, am besten höhenverstellbar,
ordentlichen Stuhl mit ordentlicher Armlehne, am besten auch höhenverstellbar, ordentlichen
Desktop-Computer, ordentlichen Bildschirm. Und die brauchen das Allerwichtigste bei
einem Homeoffice-Büro. Leute, was ist eurer Meinung nach das Wichtigste an einem Homeoffice-Arbeitsplatz?
Es gibt da eine Sache, die, finde ich, sticht raus. Ja, das geht, das geht, das geht, ja
gut, von RGB abgesehen. Ne, ne Tür, dass man seine Ruhe hat. Du brauchst was, wo du
eine Tür hast, die du zumachen kannst. Wo ist die Tür zumachen können? Das Wichtigste
bei dem, was man halt basic braucht, um Homeoffice machen zu können, wie zum Beispiel den Internet-Anschluss,
ist einfach eine Tür. Wenn dann irgendwie einer anfängt, Staub zu saugen oder was auch
immer, machst einfach die Tür zu, gut ist. Oder wenn die Leute zu sehr auf den Sack gehen,
weil laufend irgendwas ist, dann Tür zu, gut ist. Tür ist das Wichtigste, du brauchst
deine Ruhe. Vor allem, wenn du was programmierst und dir Gedanken machen musst, aber auch
bei, auch wenn du irgendwelche sinnlosen Gemiete hast, das ist halt blöd, wenn laufend irgendwie
Krach ist. Gibt's ja genug Leute, die sitzen Teams im Call und du hörst die Kinder schreien
im Hintergrund, du hörst den Nachbar beim Hackenschneiden mit der Säge. Selbst ist
das Mikrofon teilweise so schlecht, dass du das Gefühl hast, die haben es in Bobbles stecken
irgendwo. Da ist teilweise schon richtig Pepega-Time angesagt. Eja klar, jeder, nicht nur ich,
ich glaube jeden Träger, dass irgendwo wenn die Leute kacke Qualität im Voice Call haben.
Mich hat das schon genervt, wo ich noch nicht Boomer-Max war und wo ich MMOs gespielt habe
und die Leute hatten im TS so eine kacke Sound-Qualität. MMOs haben ja damals, ich weiß nicht wie
das heute ist, auch viele Hausfrauen gespielt und es war ganz schlimm, wenn man irgendwas
geradet ist oder irgendwas gemacht hat und wenn die ohne Push-to-Talk im TS waren und
die Kinder im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit rumgeschrien haben, ich bin immer so durchgedreht. Also
innerlich, ich hab mich rumgeschrien oder so, aber es hat mich immer so aufgeregt, ich
hab die Leute dann meistens gemutet, dauerhaft. Wenigstens Push-to-Talk einstellen kann man.
Ist übrigens so eine Sache, die mich an Teams nervt. Teams hat kein, ich weiß nicht vielleicht
haben sie das mittlerweile, aber meines wissen sie ja nicht, Microsoft Teams hat keine Push-to-Talk
Funktion. Ich mach das immer von Hand mit dem Mute-Button, aber und eine richtig ordentliche
Push-to-Talk Funktion wäre schon cool. Noise-canceling-Kopfhörer, ja. Oder aber eine Tür. Gut, an der Tür kann man
auch klopfen und kratzen und machen und tun, ja. Aber Noise-canceling-Kopfhörer ist tatsächlich
richtig nice. Hat sich wirklich gelohnt. Ich hab mir auch einen gekauft vor 2-3 Jahren.
Das einzige Bose-Gerät, was ich hab. Bin ja nicht der großartige Bose-Fan normalerweise,
aber die sind echt gut. Nur was mich immer verwirrt ist, manchmal willst du das Headset
anschalten, also ich hab ja dieses Teil hier, warte mal mal gucken, ob sie das überhaupt
noch verkaufen. Bose, Alter. Noise-canceling. Seht die Kacke aus mittlerweile. Was ist das?
So was hier, so was in der Richtung hab ich. So was, so ein Teil. Gut, ich sitz nie am Autoreifen
da und hab meine Noise. Was ist denn das eigentlich für ein bescheuertes Bild? Am dreckigen Autoreifen
da sitzen Angelen und Noise-canceling-Kopfhörer auf. Was ist denn das für ein Bild? So nach
dem Motto, ok ich sitz an der Straße und werd jetzt gleich vom LKW umgefahren, weil ich
ihn nicht höre oder was. Mach ich auch immer so, ja. So und wo wollt ich denn jetzt eigentlich
drauf raus, Leute? Die Mütze. Ah, die Mütze. Wart ihr eigentlich ne Mütze unter den Noise-canceling-Kopfhörer?
Wir würden eigentlich erwarten, die Haare, die Haare sind schon genug dazwischen zwischen
Kopfhörer. Ok, aber ist ja auch hipster Nasenring und so. Das ist einfach nur Foto für die
Optik. Ja und er ist ja auch, der Typ ist ja auch mega glücklich schon, weil er die Kopfhörer
hier auf hat. Also yeah. Ich könnt mir fast vorstellen, die Kopfhörer sind gefotoshopped
auf das Bild. Meint ihr, die haben den fotografiert mit Kopfhörern oder die sind photoshopped?
Ich mein ok, die Haare sind runter gedrückt oben. Das kann schon sein, dass die das wirklich
echt fotografiert haben mit dem Kopfhörer. Die haben ihn wahrscheinlich fotografiert
mit dem Kopfhörer und danach nochmal photoshopped. Naja. So zumindest die Teile hab ich mir mal
gekauft und ich muss sagen, das war echt ein sinnvoller Kauf. Also als Noise-canceling-
Kopfhörer. Achja und eine Sache, die mich dabei nervt ist, man würde eigentlich davon
ausgehen, das ist halt ein Kopfhörer, den benutzt man als Kopfhörer und gut ist, aber
nein. Manchmal machst du den Kopfhörer an und machst dann dein Smartphone an und dann
meint der Kopfhörer, bitte updaten sie die Firmware. Also wir sind schon in Zeiten, wo
man den Kopfhörer updaten muss. In dem Fall klar, ich mein, das ist ein Bluetooth-Kopfhörer.
Schon klar, dass der Firmware hat und geupdatet werden muss, aber naja. Manche Sachen sollten
einfach auch ohne Firmware-Update auskommen können. Am besten ist immer noch die Schuhe,
die Schuhe, die sich updaten wollten. Leute, das muss ich...warte mal, Twitter, Internet
auf Shit. Letztens ist ein Screenshot gesehen von Schuhen, die sich updaten wollen. Custom
Firmware auf Schuhen. Okay, das ist auch eine ziemlich beknagte Frage. Hier, hier, guckt
euch das mal an. Null. Update to latest features. Keep your phone near your right shoe. Das ist
so geil. Einfach erstmal den Schuh updaten. Hang tight. We updating your shoes with the
latest features. Vielleicht läuft man dann schneller, ja? Keine Ahnung. Was genau braucht
ein Schuh für ein Firmware-Update? To get the most out of your shoes, we need to install
an update. Haben die RGB oder so? Was sind das für Schuhe, die man updaten muss? RGB-Beleuchtung,
die blinkt dann schneller und dementsprechend rennt man auch schneller. Ich klick das jetzt
nicht an. Mich interessiert zwar, ob es einen neuen Cobalt gibt, aber ich klick keine Twitter-Trends
mehr in Deutschland an. Was sind das überhaupt für Schuhe? Hat jemand eine Ahnung? Was sind
das für Schuhe? Was ist das für ein Logo? Was ist das? Sagt mir nichts. Under Armour.
Under Armour hört sich an wie so ein Exosuit aus Cod. Under Armour. Ah ja gut, die muss
man updaten. Velocity Wind Running Shoes. Das ist Big Brain Shoes, alles klar. Ja gut,
wenn da ein Schrittezähler drin ist, dann verstehe ich das sogar. Ich meine, man würde
eigentlich erwarten, dass man einen Schrittezähler auch im Werkszustand insofern halbwegs fehlerfrei
ausgeliefert bekommt, dass man den nicht updaten muss. Aber okay, ich lasse mir es gefallen,
wenn da ein Schrittezähler ist oder das Ding irgendwie kalibriert werden muss oder frag
mich nicht. Oh nein, ich darf keine. Leute, ich darf keine Twitter-Trends anklicken. Wenn
ich das schon wieder sehe, weiß ich, ich bin getriggert, wenn ich da drauf klicke. Mansplaining
Trended. Oh Gott, ich weiß schon, das wird schlimm. Ich klicke da nicht drauf, Leute.
Ich klicke da nicht drauf. Aber das fand ich lustig, dass man Schuhe updaten muss. Okay,
great. Tja. Nee, aber die sind eigentlich echt ganz nice. Heute würde ich mir die wahrscheinlich
nicht mal kaufen. Heute würde ich mir wahrscheinlich wirklich ein paar Sony Noise Cancelling-Dinger
kaufen. Aber die Bose-Dinger waren, ich hab das ja auch schon 3-4 Jahre, jetzt waren damals
noch ein bisschen besser. Ansonsten preislich nimmt sich das ja nicht allzu viel. Wobei
ich ja sagen muss, die da versus die da, ich finde, die sehen viel besser aus als dieses
komische... Das sieht aus, die Dinger sehen aus, als bricht's gleich ab. Hallo, Amazon.
Das sieht aus, als bricht's ab. Scharf angeguckt, abgebrochen. Also heute würde ich mir wahrscheinlich
wirklich... Ja, genau, machen wir den Song. Heute würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch einen
Sony kaufen. Okay, die sehen abgedreht aus. Teufel. Haben ja auch nicht so den allerbesten
Ruf. Bluetooth. Aber Noise Cancelling-Kopfhörer machen sie mittlerweile fast alle, ne? Bose
war da einer der ersten. Oder zumindest einer der ersten, wo es richtig gut war. Jetzt gibt's
da viele Sachen. Naja, gut. Auswahl ist ja immer gut, was sowas angeht. Dann hab ich
meinen vielleicht doch noch länger als vier Jahre. Also ich weiß noch, als ich den gekauft
hab, waren die Sony-Dinger noch nicht ganz auf der Höhe. Sennheiser macht keine Kopfhörer
mehr. Echt nicht. Die machen keine Kopfhörer mehr. Was ist denn mit dem HD... Was war dieser
ganz teure HD 600? Der für 1000 Euro? Oder HD 800? Was war denn der ganz teure? Ja, der
da. Easy. Moin, Janik. Die haben echt verkauft? Also ich finde, kann man schonmal machen Kopfhörer
für 1600 Euro. Take weight. Sennheiser hat meine Seite kaputt gemacht. Wahrscheinlich
haben die an die Chinesen verkauft? Wahrscheinlich haben die Chinesen versucht, gerade irgend
Trojaner über die Seite einzudinken bei mir. Die chinesischen China-Chinesen. Ich mein,
geil sind die Dinger schon, aber mal im Ernst. Also den Preis würde ich dafür nicht ausgeben.
Oh guck mal, es gibt ja sogar mit... Warte, es geht noch teurer? What the fuck? Die sind
jetzt durchsichtig. What the fuck, Alter? Meine Fresse, jetzt übertreiben sie es aber.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber echt. Hat AKG noch... AKG hat es jetzt richtig gemacht.
Die haben diese hässlichen Knubbel entfernt an diesem Band. Ich hab ja auch noch... Also
persönlich vom Sound her gefallen mir die AKG Kopfhörer am besten, die ich hab. Ich
hab glaub ich auch. Ich hab einen K802 irgendwas oder so. Der hatte noch so komische Knubbel
und... Ich glaub so ein Teil mit Knubbel... Ja, die gibt's schon gar nicht mehr. Hier.
Aber der hat auch schon keine Knubbel mehr. Richtig hängen geblieben. Da musste man damals
sein Kopfhörer modden, um ihn bequem zu machen. Ich weiß nicht, was der Hersteller sich mit
den Knubbeln gedacht hat. Echt absoluter Wahnsinn. Naja, gut. Was auch immer. Mach das mal. Also
warum man bei einem Kopfhörerpreis von 2500 Euro noch 10 Euro versandt haben will, das
versteh ich auch nicht. Nee. Meinung zu in ihr Kopfhörer. Okay. Kann man machen. Ich wusste
gar nicht, dass du streamst. Ich stream seit zwei Jahren oder so. Nee. Seit wann stream ich,
ne? Wartet mal. Ich glaube, es ist immer länger, als ich denke. 2017 stand da... Guck mal.
Das sind fast vier Jahre schon. Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen? Zulang kommt mir das
überhaupt nicht vor. Kommt euch das wirklich so vor, als bin ich vier Jahre am Start? Kann
ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Seit 23 Minuten. Richtig. Tja. Guck mal, hier haben wir Dings,
das war Hacker in der Beta. Das war World War 2, oder? Was wir da gespielt haben. Los,
los, los. Moment, das war nicht mal der erste Stream hier. Ich hab früher angefangen zu
streamen. Ich hab ja am Anfang noch ein paar BDO Streams gemacht und so. Ich stream schon
noch länger als hier. Das ist der erste Stream, der im Archiv ist. Das ist gar nicht der erste.
Ich weiß, wie wir das rauskriegen. Ich weiß, wie wir das rauskriegen. Wir gehen einfach
auf Clips. All. Kann man das jetzt nicht nach Datum sortieren? Kann man das jetzt nicht
noch nach Datum sortieren? Nee. Twitch, warum macht ihr einem das Leben so schwer? Warum
kann ich das nicht nach Datum sortieren? Was ist das für ein Fail? Warum gibt es hier
nicht so einen Knopf? Sort by Date. Sort by Created. Warum gibt es das nicht? Root Passwort
Leak hat 2000 Aufrufe. Warum hat das Root Passwort Leak 2000 Aufrufe? Wo muss ich das
kleinschreiben? CPX. Ah, guck mal jetzt. Da wird er erstellt. Es Created, Leute. Ach,
das war wo ich Root Passwort geleakt hab. Ja, ich erinnere mich. Twitch Tracker. Wo
war das? Wie hieß diese deutsche Seite, diese deutsche Social Blade Gegenstück? Ok, zeig
mal her. Hier. Erster Stream. Juli 2017. 35 Zuschauer. Guck mal hier. Kontinuierlich
ist es gekleimt, die Zuschauerzahl. Poggers. Nindo. War das Nindo? Ja, genau. Ok, wer sind
so die erfolgreichen Leute auf aufdings? Ok, also mal gucken, auf wen ich davon kenne.
Von ihm hab ich schon mal was gehört. Weiß ich, kenne ich vom Namen her, sagt mir gar
nichts. Glaub ich PewDieYouTube oder so, ne? Das kenne ich gar nicht, kenne ich gar nicht,
kenne ich gar nicht. Ja, gut. Ja, ja. Sagt mir auch gar nichts. Nico kenne ich natürlich,
den kenne ich. Sagt mir gar nichts, ich weiß null, wer das ist. Oh, Twitter. Der Karl-Lauter-Bach-Hand-Twitter-Rekorde.
Ok, na dann. So, und da kann ich jetzt suchen nach. Auf Hublords, zeig mal her. Wer zum
Geier ist eigentlich hungriger? Hugo. Der Name klingt lustig, aber hab ich den nie gehört.
Ne, ne, ne. Alter, woher weiß der das? Woher weiß der, dass Hublords gleich Max-FPS auf
YouTube ist? AI-Blockchain. Agile AI-Blockchain-Technologie muss das da drunter sein, anders ist das
nicht möglich, dass man das erkennt. Generalslane, Dankeschön für 12 Monate Hyper-Subscription.
Gleiche Mail, nein, das sind unterschiedliche Mails. Ok, erster Stream. Erster Stream. Ja,
man weiß, dass man nix weiß. Wo sieht man hier, wann der erste Stream war? Ich bin sogar
live, stell euch mal vor. Ich hab angeblich 315 Zuschauer. Äh, nein. Das stimmt nicht,
die Seite ist ein bisschen fail. Kann man da keine History oder so? Pro Stream. Wie die
Streamzeit ab 22 Uhr runtergeht. Achso, ich bin Twitch-Rang 377? Das kann doch nicht sein.
Es gibt doch viel mehr Leute vor mir auf Twitch. Das glaub ich nicht. Es gibt doch hunderte
mittlerweile, die 1K Plus Zuschauer haben. Vermutlich in DE, ja vielleicht. Ok, hat das
Ding keine History? Erwachsene, alle Altersgruppen. Ich hab noch nie Stream für Erwachsene gemacht.
Na gut, egal. Sackt. Aber hier wissen wir was, wir haben angefangen. Angefangen Juli. Most
Streamed, Just Chatting. 839 Stunden, ey. Und Battlefield 3. Guck mal, wir haben sogar relativ
viel Battlefield 3 gestreamt, hab ich grad gedacht. Passive Exide haben wir auch mal
ein bisschen gestreamt, aber nicht viel. WTF, wie viel Sachen haben wir? Stimmt, stimmt.
Wir haben ein paar, ein bisschen Pupke haben wir auch mal gespielt. To the Moon, oh. Pepe
Hands, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Weiß nicht, da war nicht so viele dabei,
aber das war richtig Pepe Hands Stream. Das war mit dem Friseur hier. Ja, To the Moon
hat ja heute eine andere Bedeutung, ich weiß, ich weiß. Das ist immer noch geiles Game,
ist immer noch eines meiner absoluten Lieblingsspieler. Was, wir haben Rezo gesp... Retro, Retro.
Aber man sieht ganz klar was hier angesagt ist. Na gut, wie auch immer, wir gucken jetzt
ein paar Videos auf YouTube. Ich hab gehört, Dogecoin ist gecrasht, stimmt das? Zeig mal
hier. Dogecoin ist wohl heute Nacht übelst gecrasht. Na ja, naja, naja, naja, übelst
kann man jetzt vielleicht nicht sagen, aber. Na ja doch, ist schon, ist schon ein bisschen
so, oder? Ja, von 0,6 auf 0,53. Das heißt, sollte ich mir jetzt Dogecoin kaufen, Leute,
und dann danach Hodl, Hodl bis auf Bam. Ihr müsst das wie Unge machen, erstmal 100k in
Dogecoin. Nee, nicht 100k, eine Million war das doch, oder? Eine Million in Krypto oder
wie war denn, wie ging das noch? Weil ich hab das nur aus dem Rand mitgekriegt, das war
eine Million sogar. Eine Million in Krypto, easy. Hättest du machen sollen bei 0? Ja,
ja, hätte, hätte, ja, hätte. Nachher bist du immer schlauer. Hier, hier hättest du
machen. Ja, nachher bist du natürlich immer schlauer. Und das alles, weil wohl Elon Musk
in irgendeiner Talkshow was Schlechtes über Dogecoin gesagt hat, dann alle so, oh nein,
Elon hat gesagt, das ist schlecht, flupp. Hab ich in den News Beitrag heute Morgen gelesen.
Jetzt handelt, die machen immer Werbung auf Twitter bei mir. Ich krieg immer E-Toro-Werbung.
Jetzt weiß ich wenigstens, was das ist. Ja, es wird eh mal Zeit, dass Grafikkarten wieder
bezahlbar sind. So, jetzt gucken wir uns ein paar YouTube Videos an. Mit was fangen wir
dann an? Ich hab random einfach, die von den letzten, die wir nicht geguckt haben, aufgemacht
plus noch ein paar andere. Mal gucken, jetzt hat YouTube noch einmalig die Chance uns ein
Massive-Video zu empfehlen, was wir schon immer mal sehen wollten und zwar das da anscheinend.
Okay. Ich könnte mich wieder wegpissen bei diesen Videos. Davon gibt es Milliarden Videos
von. Aber die sind teilweise echt lustig. Das ging jetzt war jetzt nicht so. Oh, Semper
Video hat ein Home Assistant Video gemacht. Okay, Leute, das müssen wir uns jetzt mal
angucken. Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir da viel Neues erfahren,
aber ich würde mal interessieren, was der damit macht. Okay, wie könnte der Home Assistant
aussprechen? Der spricht ja die Sachen immer so super betont und korrekt aus. Provider,
der Provider. Das heißt, der sagt dann wahrscheinlich Home Assistant. Semper Video kann man unglaublich
schlecht nachmachen. Home Assistant, könnte er sagen. Der Home Assistant. Egal, wenn wir
mal anhören. Home Assistant. Der Home Assistant. Ja. Okay, das kommt man jetzt an. Also zeig
mal her. Wo habe ich meine Musik laufen? Ich glaube nicht, dass wir viel Neues erfahren
würden, aber mich interessiert, was der mit Home Assistant macht. Das sagt er immer am
Anfang. Das ist eigentlich die neue Begrüßung bei ihm. In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Das sagt er fast in jedem Video mittlerweile. Hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz die erste
Folge der nicht enden wollenden Serie rund um die Heimautomation. Das smarte Heim ist
nicht neu und die Produkte werden immer vielfältiger. Waschmaschine, Geschirr, Spüler, Roller, Fenster,
Kühlschrank. Trockner, Trockner. Ich möchte an der Stelle nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass
jemand bei seinem LG Trockner festgestellt hat, dass der 1 Gigabyte Daten Daily hoch
und runter lädt. Also so viel zu Smart Home Geräten. Versteht man was oder muss ich lauter
machen? So ist gut, ne? Ja, da reicht es. Die Basics sozusagen
Smarte Steckdose. Ja, das stimmt. Aber mit smarten Steckdosen, Chat, mit smarten Steckdosen
kennen wir uns ja nun wirklich mehr als genug aus. Zum Beispiel um alte Geräte, die noch
nicht smart sind, smart zu machen. Vom Nachtlicht für die Kleinen, eventuell bis zur Stehlampe
im Wohnzimmer oder als Kill-Switch für den eigenen Computer. Kill-Switch, Bonkers. Hier
jetzt die Variante von zum Beispiel TP-Link, eine Smarte Steckdose, schaltet sich übers
W-Line ein und kann dann mit der entsprechenden App ferngesteuert werden. TP-Link hat sich
nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert. Ah, übrigens, die haben wir geflasht letztens im Stream,
diese Steckdosen, die ihr jetzt zeigt. Aber TP-Link hat sich nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert,
gerade in Zusammenarbeit mit Home Assistant. Die hatten ja die ganze Zeit eine lokale API,
dass man die lokal steuern kann, ohne dass man eine Cloud gebraucht hat. Und ich habe
die von heute auf morgen abgeschaltet. Und dann gab es so einen riesen Shitstorm, wo
die tatsächlich mal drauf gehört haben, und jetzt kann man die lokale API wieder benutzen.
Ich kann es aus erster Hand nicht bestätigen oder widerlegen oder sonst wie. Ich habe keine
TP-Link Steckdosen. Das war für mich aber so ein Warnsignal, dass ich gesagt habe, nein,
ich kaufe mir auch keine TP-Link Steckdosen. Weil wenn ihr den Hang dazu habt, ihre lokalen
Sachen mit einem Firmware-Update aus quasi rauszupatchen, ist schon Fail.
Wie kann man eine lokale API ausschalten? Naja, in dem machst du ein Firmware-Update,
wo die einfach nicht mehr aktiv ist. Keine Ahnung, worüber du redest. Naja, dass du
die Steckdosen steuern kannst, ohne dass du eine Internetverbindung brauchst, um es mal
ganz billig zu sagen. Die meisten der Smart Home Geräte, die so verkauft werden, brauchen
irgendeine Cloud in irgendeiner Form. Also brauchen irgendeine Internetverbindung nach
China, nach USA, nach Frankreich, nach Irland, nach Frankfurt, was auch immer. Und dass sie
funktionieren. Ich sehe das nicht ein, dass meine Steckdosen abhängig ist von der Internetverbindung
und ich sehe es auch nicht ein, dass der Hersteller überhaupt wissen muss, wann ich meine Steckdose
an und aus mache. Und deswegen ist es gut, wenn man die lokal
steuern kann. Dann kann man die nämlich auch in ein eigenes Netzwerk stecken, was gar kein
Internetzugang hat. Dafür habe ich ja extra zwei verschiedene WLANs. Einmal einen...
Ich sage bloß, meine Taste geht wieder kaputt. Meine Control-Taste. Logitech. Crap, alter.
Ne, anscheinend doch nicht. Ja, und deswegen ist es wichtig, dass man das lokal steuern
kann. Ansonsten hast du das Problem, wie mit diesen Thermostate, die über AWS gelaufen
sind, wo die Leute ihre Heizung nicht mehr ein- und ausschalten oder steuern konnten,
weil AWS down war. Gibt es ein Tutorial von dir, wie man das mit
seinem eigenen Netzwerk machen kann? Da kann ich kein Tutorial zu machen, weil das komplett
davon abhängt, was du für Hardware hast und was du machen willst. Das kann man so allgemein
gar nicht sagen. Beste. Viel besser. Viel besser. Viel besser.
Viel besser, weil, weil, die haben wir nämlich im Stream gehabt, die ist gut, weil die kannst
du flashen mit Custom-Firmware und dann hast du nie wieder Probleme mit China Cloud und
sonstigen Dingen. Custom-Firmware drauf und die hat zweimal USB unten. Und du kannst
das USB schalten übers Netzwerk. Also das riecht spock. Ich überlege gerade,
habe ich die, habe ich aktuell gerade irgendwo eine angeschlossen davon?
Ja, natürlich, natürlich, im Bad. Im Bad habe ich eine angeschlossen, Leute. Ich zeige
euch mal kurz, ich zeige euch mal kurz für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben, das
Web-Interface. Ich werde jetzt aber nicht schalten da drin.
Gosund, Gosund, dual socket, zweimal USB, da ist es.
So, wenn man das geflashed hat, sieht das Web-Interface so aus von der Steckdose. Ist
aktuell im Bad, da hängt mein, da hängt ein ESP32 dran am USB im Bad, der dafür zuständig
ist die Waage, die Bluetooth Waage, Thermostat und den Kühl, den, den, den Temperatursensor
aus dem Kühlschrank zu übertragen zu, zu meiner Heimautomatisierung. Ja, und es ist
halt auch noch eine normale Steckdose dran, wo man dann beispielsweise einen Heizlüfter
oder irgendwas reinstecken könnte oder, oder meinen Rasierer zum Beispiel, einen Rasierer
mache ich da rein. So, und da, ich glaube das hier ist USB und
das hier ist 230 Volt und das Coole an der Steckdose ist, die kann auch noch, man muss
sie aber kalibrieren, die kann sogar noch Verbrauch messen. Natürlich ist das nur am
Rande toll, also, also man muss, man muss eine finden, die man flashen kann und es bringt
dir ja nichts, wenn du hier ein Web-Interface hast, du musst das Ganze in deine Heimautomatisierung
integrieren. Das geht hiermit auch wunderbar, weil die unterstützt quasi mehr oder weniger
alles an Protokollen, was du so brauchst, um das einzubinden. Ja, und ich glaube das
waren diese Steckdosen. Was heißt denn China Cloud eigentlich? Laufen
die nicht alle über AWS, weil die in Deutschland stehen? Nein. Das ganze Tuya Zeug ist China
Cloud. Es kann durchaus sein, dass die auch irgendwelche Instanzen in Deutschland AWS
haben, aber das ganze Tuya Zeug ist der Inbegriff von China Cloud. Das ist im Prinzip, im Prinzip
ist alles dieses Zeug, ist unter der Haube Tuya. Deswegen kann man es auch wunderbar
flashen ohne aufzumachen, wenn man Glück hat. Ja, aber die Dinger sind echt okay, habt
ihr gerade gesehen. Wie gesagt, USB, 230 Volt, getrennt voneinander schaltbar, Web-Interface,
gut integrierbar, flashbar. Man muss halt gucken, dass man eine erwischt, die sich noch
flashen lässt. Dann ist top. Das ist günstiger, weswegen man früher
oder später halt mehrere verschiedene Varianten im Heim hat. Und das Problem ist, dass jede
von diesen Varianten oder von den IoT-Geräten, die smarten Anwendungen, die bringen auch
alle die eigene App mit. Aber, haha, nicht wenn man sie mit custom
Firmware flasht. Ich habe auch fünf verschiedene Steckdosen alle mittags modal geflasht. Ich
gehe mal davon aus, dass der auch gleich noch was sagen wird in der Richtung.
Und da hat man dann auf dem Handy irgendwie ein halbes Dutzend Apps. Und da reden wir
zurzeit immer noch nur von Steckdosen. Also, dass hier x verschiedene Geräte Chaos entstehen
lassen können, das ebenfalls nicht neu, weswegen es getreu dem Motto einringen, um sie alle
zu knechten, Entwickler gibt, die Anwendungen erstellt haben, mit denen sich alle Geräte
oder zumindest fast alle Geräte mit einer Oberfläche steuern lassen. Und hier hat ebenfalls
wieder der Nutzer die Auswahl. Es gibt verschiedene. Wir machen das Ganze jetzt hier in den nächsten
Videos eben mit dem Home Assistant. Ich finde auch, dass Home Assistant gerade für
Leute, die damit neu anfangen, das Beste ist. Es gibt ja ein paar verschiedene Geräte.
Du hast Open Hub als Heimautomatisierungslösung. Das fällt bei mir schon mal raus. Chat, eine
Frage. Habt ihr eine Ahnung warum Open Hub bei mir rausfällt? Ich verrat's, es ist Java
basiert. Java basiert kommt mir nix ins Haus. So, dann hast du noch früher Femme. Das ist
Pearl basiert. Das ist nicht Naisu. Das ist Pearl basiert und sieht aus wie von 1995.
So sieht halt schon ein bisschen kaputt aus. Aber unterstützt halt gerade im deutschsprachigen
Raum ist es relativ beliebt. Dann hast du IO Broker. Das ist noch das nächste was ich
eigentlich verwenden würde nach Home Assistant. Da hast du wohl den Vorteil gegenüber Home
Assistant, dass du halt so Kleinkram, ich hab's noch nicht verwendet, aber du kannst
wohl relativ viel Kleinkram sehr detailliert konfigurieren. Ich weiß von manchen die verwenden
Home Assistant mit IO Broker zusammen und quasi dort wo es keine gescheite Anbindung
an Home Assistant gibt, IO Broker, was auch immer. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was
der Vorteil ist, ich hab's noch nicht verwendet, aber IO Broker ist so das zweite was ich ins
Auge fassen würde wenn ich die Home Assistant verwenden, im Einsatz hätte. Eine Sache die
bei Home Assistant wirklich gut ist, ich kann euch immer noch nicht mein Dashboard zeigen
weil ich da zu viel leake. Das gute an Home Assistant ist echt die Oberfläche. Na gut,
mein Dark Reader soll ich vielleicht ausmachen, sonst sieht es kacke aus. Also die Home Assistant
Oberfläche ist wirklich super. Da kannst du nicht sagen das ist clean, du kannst das
alles einstellen wenn du willst. Du hast easy hier deine Controls, die sich auch super anpassen
aufs Tablet oder aufs Smartphone. Gibt doch Dark Theme, sieht aber hässlich aus. Das ist
so das Default Dashboard. Du hast Controls für alle wichtigen Sachen, für Klimageräte
mit verschiedenen Modi. Also Oberfläche, Oberflächentechnik ist Home Assistant das beste. Und dadurch
das Home Assistant so verbreitet ist, man muss halt auch mal sehen, guckt euch das mal
an. Wenn man Home Assistant sich anguckt auf GitHub, es hat 42.000 Sterne, das ist saumäßig
verbreitet, das heißt es gibt auch für so gut wie alles eine Home Assistant Integration.
So, mal gucken wie das bei IO Broker aussieht. IO Broker ist bei weitem nicht so beliebt,
hat nur, ich meine man kann Shithub Sterne nicht unbedingt als reinen Maßstab nehmen,
aber ich glaube als Indikator wie beliebt ein Projekt ist und wie verbreitet ist schon
relativ offensichtlich welches der beiden Projekte hier verbreitet ist.
Ist auf jeden Fall, die Auswahl ist auf jeden Fall groß. Dann gibt es, es gibt natürlich
noch komplette Lösungen, sowas wie Homematic oder sowas, habe ich mich nie mit beschäftigt.
Ich wollte da so möglichst viel Einfluss, ja ich weiß typischer Corona-House, ich wollte
da so viel wie möglich Einfluss selbst drauf haben, wie ich das konfiguriere und was ich
da alles einbinde. Ja, du hast noch fertige Lösungen, du hast Homematic, du hast, wie
heißt dieses andere, Loxon oder so, Loxon, Loxon, irgendwie sowas gibt es noch.
Dann irgendwie noch dieses ganze KNX oder wie das heißt, basierte, habe ich mich alles
nicht mit beschäftigt, es ist aber auch eher was, wenn man ein Haus baut und gleich quasi
das Haus im Hinblick auf Heimautomatisierung baut.
Ansonsten, im Prinzip gibt es eigentlich von den großen, es gibt Homesys und Open Hub
und die anderen zwei, die ich euch gezeigt habe. Es gibt noch jede Menge andere, aber
das dürften so die verbreitetsten Open Source Dinger sein.
Und aus dem Pool. Okay, die Installationen müssen wir uns nicht angucken, das ist langweilig.
Das ist langweilig, ich dachte, er zeigt ein bisschen was, wie er es im Einsatz hat. Installationen
haben wir hier auch im Stream schon oft genug gemacht, das ist nicht so spannend.
Das ist halt echt der Vorteil von Homesys und die unterstützen alles irgendwie.
Was für ein günstiges Tablet würdest du empfehlen als Homesys in Steuerung für die Wohnung?
Ja einfach irgendein x-beliebiges Tablet, was du schon hast. Also sprich das Tablet,
was du täglich verwendest, da kannst du ohne Probleme Homesys drauf auch installieren.
Wenn du ein Tablet meinst, was du einfach an die Wand hängen kannst an manchen Stellen,
da habe ich einen Fire HD 10 für. Aber das muss man entamazonifizieren, dass sich das
lohnt und auch nicht jetzt kaufen, sondern an Weihnachten kaufen, wenn das 80 Euro billiger
ist. Gibt sich, du kannst auch einen Fire HD 8 nehmen,
aber immer veramazonifizieren. Das sind dann aber Tablets, die sind nicht wirklich was
für einen täglichen Betrieb, das ist eher was zum an die Wand hängen, zum Steuern.
Ich habe ja im Flur neben der Gegensprechanlage jeweils oben und unten zwei Tablets hängen,
wo man, wenn man vorbeiläuft, schnell was machen kann, wo man eine Vorschau hat, beispielsweise
von der Kamera, wenn es geklingelt hat und sowas. Aber ansonsten würde ich ehrlich gesagt,
wenn du ein Tablet haben willst für Heimautomatisierung und ein Tablet, was du auch so verwendest,
hol dir ein Iphone, äh ein Ipad, hol dir ein Ipad, 300 kostet glaube ich 300, kostet
ein aktuelles Ipad, 370 oder so, nicht kein Pro, das kleine 379 oder sowas.
Also wenn du es einfach nur benutzen willst und zusätzlich auch dein Home Assistant mit
steuern willst, hol dir ein Ipad, dann hast du die wenigsten Probleme mit. Einfach nur
zum benutzen. Manche Sachen kannst du mit dem Ipad nicht machen, aber ich glaube das
willst du in dem Fall dann auch nicht machen, wenn das ein Tablet ist, was du auch täglich
verwendest. Ich habe beispielsweise bei meinen Android Tablets es so eingestellt, dass die
automatisch die Kamera öffnen, wenn jemand an der Tür klingelt. Das ist aber natürlich
bei einem Tablet, was man täglich verwendet, nicht so sinnvoll. Du willst es ja nicht haben
und das geht dann automatisch, entsperrt sich und geht automatisch was auf und sowas. Das
will man ja da eigentlich nicht haben. Bei einem Tablet, was an der Wand hängt, nur zur
Steuerung ist es wieder was anderes. Also ein Tablet rein zur Home Automation Steuerung
an der Wand, würde ich den Android nehmen, fürs tägliche benutzen, würde ich ein Ipad
nehmen und die Home Assistant App drauf machen oder die PWA oder so verwenden.
Es gibt schon keine ernst zu nehmende Alternative zum Ipad. Naja, ich finde es gibt zwei Tablets,
die sich lohnen. Das ist das Fire HD 10, Fire HD 8 von Amazon, wenn es wirklich günstig
sein soll und das aber auch kaufen am Prime Day oder an Weihnachten. Da muss man aber
Abstriche auch machen, was die Performance angeht oder an den Ipad. Es gibt sicherlich
noch die einen oder anderen, aber ich finde 379 Euro ist das für das, was man beim Ipad
bekommt, an Tablets schon echt nicht verkehrt. Sollte man die Akkus ausbauen für Wandmontage,
habe ich nicht gemacht. Ich habe einfach einen ganz normalen USB Ladekabel die ganze Zeit
dran und es juckt es nicht. Na gut, okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht
angucken, der installiert das jetzt, das ist nicht so spannend. Jaja, okay, das ist Sprecher.
Weiß man eigentlich wie der heißt? Ich meine Sprecher, wird es ja nicht sein. Weiß man
bestimmt. Andreas, aha, okay, okay. Ich sehe hier Semper Video, Stellzer sind am Start,
die wissen Bescheid. San Andreas, oh Fates Champ. Okay, also, wir lassen uns jetzt mal
eine Runde noch von Level Cap G-Baden, was es Neues gibt bei Battlefield. Übrigens absolut
lächerlich, Battlefield 6 Trailer Audio League. Ich habe mich so kaputt gelacht, dass die
jetzt wirklich Audio-Analyse von vermeintlichem Trailer-Audio, ey, so fail, Alter, so fail.
Massive, Massive, sag mal, ist irgendwas bei Level Cap nicht Massive? Alles was der jedes
Mal erzählt ist huge und Massive und sonst was, gibt es keine anderen Superlative mehr.
Sein Ding. Oh nein. So fail. So fail, Leute, so fail. Heute machen wir uns schon Gedanken
über den, über den, nicht über den Battlefield Trailer, sondern über den Sound eines vermeintlichen
Battlefield Trailers. Ja, das haben, doch, doch, das stimmt, das stimmt. Also ich bin
mir, ich bin mir da relativ sicher, das stimmt. Also gerade das Landschaft, der Landschafts-Screenshot,
den man gesehen hat, der war denke ich schon echt. Das stimmt. Naja. Naja. Naja. Naja.
Das war aber nichts Gescheites dabei. Ja, das letzte Jahr war voll mit irgendwelchen
sinnlosen Leaks, aber so wirklich dabei war ja nix. Okay, wenn wir eins wissen, die vertrauenswürdigste
Quelle im Internet war und ist und wird immer sein 4chan.
Angeblich, da sieht man auch mal, wo die ganzen Leaker falsch gelegen haben. Das erste Leak
war vorletzte Woche Freitag und das letzte nächste Leak war letzte Woche Freitag, also
den letzten Freitag und wo ist der Battlefield Trailer? Noch nirgendwo zu sehen. Und diese
ganzen Leaks sind eh absichtlich von EA durchsickern lassen, bin ich mir sehr, sehr sicher. Jedes
größte Game hat das. Sogar iPhones haben das. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern? Könnt
ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo der eine Typ, das neue iPhone in der Bar hat liegen lassen?
Ganz zufällig.
Oh ja, oh ja, die sind so exciting, die Battlefield Leaks. Was ist zu leise?
Was interessiert mich Apex? Ach nee, Warzone. Ne. Doch. Ich hab irgendwie gedacht Apex.
Das juckt mich so gar nicht. Leute, ich hab Warzone zuletzt gespielt vor einem halben
Jahr oder so. Ich hoffe ja, die kriegen das hin in Battlefield.
Juckt mich nicht. Juckt mich nicht, was hat er sonst noch drin? Ja Moment, das kenn ich
schon. Also ich mein, Mario 64 gerade seit dem Source Code Leak auf GitHub, oder das
war ja kein wirklicher Source Code Leak, oder? Die haben das doch irgendwie decompiled, Mario
64, gibt's ja auf GitHub. Gibt's ja da zigtausende Mods von. Es gibt sogar einen Multiplayer Mod
mittlerweile, Mario 64 Multiplayer Mod. Battle Royale ist an sich schon nicht der richtige
Modus für High, äh, was hat er gesagt? Highly Competitive Esport Matches. Hat mal jemand
von euch Pupke, Pupke Esport gesehen aus Korea, da pisst ihr euch weg. Da liegt ein Vierer
Squad im Gras und macht am Ende drei Kills und gewinnt. Das ist wirklich absolut lächerlich.
Pupke Esport. Weiß nicht, ob die Regeln nicht mittlerweile besser sind, weiß ich, aber das
ist echt, das ist echt der Witz. Das ist echt komplett der Witz. Und ihr kennt, ihr
kennt die koreanischen, äh, Kommentator, warte mal, also, die, die, das ist Legendary,
ich muss euch jetzt mal zeigen, für die, die es noch nicht gehört haben, äh, Korean Hype
Common Terry oder so. Die, die, die flippen, die flippen tot, die flippen total aus.
Die sind immer voll am eskalieren, die Koreaner beim casten. Und die Fangirls schreien rum
und so. So, ok, jetzt kennt ihr den normalen koreanischen Casting Style. Und jetzt überlegt
euch mal, diese Leute müssen ein Pupke Turnier casten, wo nicht passiert, aus einer halben
Stunde im Gras rumgeliege. Und die versuchen das zu Hypen. Die, die, die versuchen das
zu Hypen. Und das ist genauso wie, wie, wie, wie wenn du dann englische Kommentators anhörst,
die quasi bei jedem Movement sagen, oh, it's getting pretty intense, pretty intense, oh,
es geht, nein, da ist nix intense, der Typ ist zwei Zentimeter im Gras vorgerobbt. Nix
passiert. Und das ist echt, das ist echt lächerlich. Es gibt bloß noch eine Sache,
die das ganze noch toppt. Und das ist Mobile, Mobile Tablet Game Esport. Das ist das beste.
Tablet Esport. Wie hieß das? Wie hieß dieses, wie hieß dieses eine Game? Clash? Was Clash
Royal? Ich weiß es nicht. Ne, ne. Oder doch? Ja? Alter! Clash Royal Esport! Da sitzen
sie an den Tablets mit 150 APM. Das ist noch schlimmer, das ist noch schlimmer als PUBG
Esport, ey. The fuck, Alter? Naja, okay, okay, was auch immer. Es, es, es hat anscheinend
ein Viewer, ja? Die Tablets haben RGB, der ganze Raum hat RGB wahrscheinlich, dass du
das den ganzen Tag spielen kannst. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Ja. Die letzten, das, das, das, auf der Switch, die All-Star-Collections waren besserer Witz.
Die bei CS campt keiner. Zeig mir einen Pro-Match in CS, wo richtig gecampt wird. Damit gewinnt
sie ja nichts. Och, hab ich? Oh, ja. Oh, ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
die klitsches funktionieren
außerdem wartet in cs kaum jemand ja also es ist ok man könnte sagen taktisches
wand aber es ist äußerst selten dass in cs wirklich jemand zwei minuten auf die
gleiche ecke guckt das kommt mal vor aber das sind meistens 15 20 sekunden
je nach timing wo halt geguckt wird ob da einer kommt und danach wird ein stückchen
rotiert und geguckt und ich habe ich habe ich habe gestern ich habe gestern
vorgestern vorgestern ein valorant match geguckt weil weil der team manager also
ich kenne ich kenne den manager von dem von dem team und ich habe halt gar nicht
guckt mal rein guckt mal rein und die haben den spieler der heißt ficken ok
ficken ist es eigentlich aber das spricht man auf deutsch ficken und dann
hat einer der dann hat einer der kommentatoren gesagt wie kriege ich das
jetzt also wählen valorant valorant kommen wählen valorant kommentatoren
meint dann irgendwie aber wie hat er das ausgedrückt
ficken ent den mini schlitz ab habe ich mir gedacht ok leute wenn man das
außerhalb von valorant commentary hört das klingt falsch
den mini schlitz Leute zum Glück ist das in valorant ist manche call outs sind
halt schon in kombination mit dem spieler namen dann vielleicht nicht so
glücklich ich muss ich muss eins ich muss mal was was kurz sagen das hier sogar
ganz gut gemacht aber ihr kennt doch sicherlich diese videos so nach dem
motto ocarina of time in unreal 4 und sowas wo dann irgendwie einer so irgendwie
irgendwie so eine szenen aus ocarina of time nach macht die sehen zwar immer
recht gut aus weil andere gute effekte und so hat aber das sieht immer falsch
aus immer nicht passen zu dem game und ich muss sagen das hier haben sie
eigentlich ganz gut gemacht und klar sie haben ja auch das originale game dafür
zum modden das sieht noch verhältnismäßig gut aus
klar kann man sagen irgendwie passt so ultra realistisches wasser nicht zu
mario 64 oder auch so in diese schatten hier immer guckt euch den zaubern dazu
an diese schatten aber hey ok das sieht immer noch ganz gut aus besser als die
ganzen unreal 4 remakes die keine remake sind und nie fertig werden
to improve over time the witcher threes developers are working on next gen
ports of the iconic game but it's all be leaning on community mods a witcher
drei wird das neue skyrims they reportedly in talks with the developers
of witcher 3 hd reworked mod to incorporate it officially the mod
replaces all of the games textures with ai upscale
ai upscale adjusted for accuracy it's a pretty impressive mod there remains true
to the games original vision while cleaning up all the compromises that had
to be made for the game to be playable on the hardware of its time the pc port
und auf das switch darf man ja nicht vergessen ich sage euch wünschen drei
irgendwann gibt es auch für alexa
or for playstation exclusive days gone is shaping up to be very impressive new
official screenshots of the port show incredibly detailed character models
with absolutely gorgeous lighting days gone was a generally good looking game
when it debuted on the playstation 4 and it runs pretty well on the next gen
hardware but these new screenshots show its true potential the pc version of
days gone launches on may 18th the launch of resident evil village is
blowing past franchise records it has the highest peak player count of any
resident evil game on steam and it's known sich das lohnt sich das ich war
kurz davor ist mir zu kaufen starting in the top 10 most popular games across
the entire platform while that's somewhat expected given the hype surrounding
die obei leute gibt es das überhaupt für den pc
bilde mir ein schon ok gut kann ich für mich kaufen it seems entirely earned reviews
of the game rave about its quality gameplay story and visuals user reviews
are also very poflocked is currently sitting at around 80.000 concurrent players
ich könnte resident evil kann man das auch auf stadia spielen leute gibt es
das gibt es das auch auf stadia dann muss ich das natürlich unbedingt auf
stadia speichert 20.000 of course the game was coming out of the back of the
franchise was reviewed games and had a lot to prove but it's turned out to be
one of the best resident evil games yet by all accounts village is another slam
dunk mass effect legendary edition is making a lot of gameplay tweaks across
the original trilogy of games but it sounds like at least one of those
tweaks will be optional the notorious mako landing craft will allow players to
switch from updated controls to the original ones those original controls
were notably frustrating for most players in the original mass effect and
have been overhauled for the remaster also tweaked gameplay elements to make
using it more forgiving like lava no longer instantly ending the mission if
you touch it but for those true fans out there you'll be able to toggle on the
original controls and slide your way across the planets like mad lads before
we get to our final story today just a reminder that will have full coverage of
everything the battlefield trailer reveals when it actually drops ja ach
nein das damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet gut dass er das sagt ich
hätte gedacht level cap macht aus jeder möckenden elefant was leaks angeht
aber den trailer cover der dann nicht
greift in turn on notifications so you don't miss that video and also stay
tuned for continuing coverage of all things gaming the next gen upgrade of
cyberpunk noir game observer is coming to last gen consoles on july 16th the
overhaul is a pretty incredible transformation that updates the game's
visuals while also adding new content it stars the late wrecker how or blade
runner fame as the game's main character or sind die box auch gefixt
looking for a son the upgrade will run you $30 and is the definitive version of
the game was getting it running a moment moment
verstehe ich das jetzt richtig die wollen 30 dollar noch mal zusätzlich
für cyberpunk oder blick ich jetzt nicht durch
das habe ich das habe ich falsch verstanden oder
non last gen hardware sounds like no small feet and it's pretty impressive
das ist nicht sein aber das ist was anderes ja ja ok ja ach das ist
observer dass sie brain brain leg das ist ein ganz anderes game alter ok ok ja ja
man kann ja schon mal verwirrt sein jetzt and that wraps it up for today in
gaming thank you guys so much for watching and i'll see you next time this
is level ok irgendjemand hat link gepostet zu einer mario 64 unreal remake
das ist pains champ diese remakes ich sag's euch die sehen komplett falsch
aus
ok tom tendo ich weiß nicht ob ich was ich muss ich schreue mal kurz durch es
gibt so ein paar channels auf youtube die kuck ich nicht gerne es hat nichts mit
den leuten an sich zu tun aber ich kann es gibt es gibt paar channels die kann
ich mir nicht lange angucken unter anderem tom tendo und alexi beck sie das
sind so zwei zwei kandidaten ich kenne ich habe ich kenne die leute nicht ich
habe nix gegen die leute ich kann mir die videos einfach nur nicht angucken
ja das sieht einfach falsch aus sieht einfach falsch aus
aber das ist jetzt noch recht hübsch gemacht
sogar mario sieht ok ist das ist es das galaxy model ne das von 2008
ich bin mal gespannt ich bin mal gespannt ob er die details richtig
das ist ich also ich habe keine ahnung ich habe mit unreal 4 noch nie was
gemacht aber ich könnte mir vorstellen so was in unreal 4 zu erstellen ist nicht
großartiges hexenwerk oder in unity oder so ich glaube das ist nicht
sonderlich schwer und man kriegt das relativ easy also natürlich wird es ein
wird es ein paar tage dauern aber man kriegt das glaube ich relativ easy hin
ja ist ja gut jetzt bewegung ist wichtig ok movement sieht schon mal komplett
falsch aus
movement die bäume sehen auch prognose aus ja man kann nicht klattern ok
movement sieht definitiv nicht richtig aus überhaupt gar nicht sieht es
richtig aus das movement
das ist auch so ein ding was nie fertig wird das ist irgend einer der quasi zum
üben in im unreal 4 baukasten halt mal das mario 64 schloss nachgebaut hat
draußen kamera ist auch ein bisschen weird zumindest
nicht original wobei man halt sagen muss die originale mario 64 kamer aber auch
komisch
ich war wenigsten sieht es optisch ganz ok aus wobei das alles in ziemlich
übertriebenen glow hat
mario s das sieht halt gut aus weil unreal gut aussieht default mäßig
auch die ich muss sagen ich bin immer nicht sonderlich beeindruckt von diesen
dingern
ich habe keine ahnung von unreal 4 aber ich kann oder von unity aber ich könnte
mir halt echt vorstellen das ist kein allzu großer akt sowas zu bauen du
wirst wahrscheinlich die meisten sachen schon fertig bekommen du wirst in mario
model definitiv fertig bekommen umsonst krass geschichten wird wahrscheinlich
eingebaut sein die bäume sehen als auch nicht so nicht kompliziert das level zu
bauen ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht so das großartige problem dass mario schloss
gibt wahrscheinlich auch schon fix und fertig irgendwo einen controller für das
movement mario 64 gibt garantiert auch schon einen kostenlosen umsonst
wahrscheinlich ist das mehr oder weniger die sachen zusammengesteckt und das
level gebaut also
so das dauert noch nicht mal einen monat ich gehe mal davon aus jemand der
ahnung hat von unreal 4 macht sowas in zwei drei tagen
könnte sein dass ich komplett falsch liege aber ich glaube so viel ist das nicht
ja das movement sieht auch auch gott es sieht richtig verkehrt aus
die wasser effekte sind unreal wasser effekt die sehen halt nun mal gut aus
es ist jetzt ja ich meine es sieht schon cool aus aber es ist jetzt nicht so als
wäre dass der verdienst des modders dass es wasser so gut
aussieht das ist wahrscheinlich default unreal wasser
das ist ja kein mod sie soll noch nicht mal mod
fisch ei aber fischer ei macht nix fisch ei schwimmt einfach im kreis
wo ist die fisch ei keine fisch ei leute
ja call of duty ghost besser konfirm
die kommen nach den comments kannst du nicht gehen die konterleute haben ja
absolut kein plan gerade bei dom tendo alter
ja
das das finde ich immer sieht immer falsch aus
aber hier bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
er steht falsch
ja
funktioniert nicht das haben die sogar in ocarina of time schon hingekriegt
ich glaube ocarina of time war eines der ersten games was das verwendet hat mit
dass die füße sich dem untergrund nach ausrichten ich letztens
top bei sam gesehen in dem video der kennt sich auch mit so was aus
inverse kinematics genau cinematics kinematics wie man das ausspricht genau
so hieß das hat er gibt's hier nicht
das würde ich schon mal erwarten das sind also details so sagen mit hey das
wäre halt wirklich cool wenn man das macht deswegen das gerade weil solche
details auch nicht drin sind glaube ich eben das ist nicht das movement sieht
so falsch aus dass das kein großer act ist und das schloss muss man
wahrscheinlich mal selbst bauen das mario 64 schloss gibt es wahrscheinlich im
asset store für umsonst strides 22 monate hyper subscription dankeschön für
den zapp
ich eq ja ich finde dies es gibt ja auch 30 30 soll 30.000 solcher mods und
ocarina of time einfach wie remake und so was das sieht alles immer ultra falsch
aus
darf ich während der ausgangssperre auf meinen balkon gehen ich würde sagen ja
oder ich darf ja auch in meinen hof gehen
man hätte theoretisch urheberrechtsprobleme wahrscheinlich ja
aber nintendo juckt das ja nicht ob es im asset store mario 64 schloss gibt oder
ob man das irgendwo auf github bekommt oder sowas
ok was guckt man als nächstes ssd kill killa ich habe chia krypto fahrt das ist
das das ist die storage kryptowährung das guckt man jetzt mal an der hour der
auer der auer was erzählen wupp wupp wupp wupp
hallo zusammen herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren video und heute auch
etwas kontroverseren thema und zwar geht es um das thema schia farming aus
relativ guten grund gab es auf meinem kanal bisher kein video zum thema
bitcoin mining ich habe das früher zweimal gemacht zur hd 5000er serie also
ich bin auch kein heiliger in wirklich keine da hat er wahrscheinlich 30
bitcoin ist millionär damit geworden easy aber ich habe aber er hat
wahrscheinlich genug kohle ein bisschen geändert über die jahre zu diesem
thema einfach mal was ressourcenverbrauch ressourcenverschwendung
sage ich laut genug was das ganze thema mining betrifft natürlich auf
stromverbrauch man schätzt ja hast ein bisschen auseinander man schätzt
irgendwo zwischen 50 und 150 terawattstunden verbrauch pro jahr durch
speedcoin mining und so zur einordnung österreich hat so 70 bis 75 terawattstunden
ja gut österreichische relativ krass wie der einfluss von bitcoin mining dann auf
die umwelt ist und natürlich auch für uns siehst du regelmäßig die hardware
und die harte ist heute erst zu streben ja ja schon verfügbarkeit öfters öfters
war habe ich das eigentlich nicht weiter unterstützt oder wollte das weiter
befeuern jetzt gibt es neues und zwar nennt sich das schia bei bitcoin ist es
ja so dass man mit diesem proof of work konzept arbeitet das bedeutet ja man
hat eben die grafikkarten die arbeit verrichten und dadurch generiert
generiert letztendlich der bitcoin sein ich habe wenig ahnung von
kryptowährung ich glaube die das eigentliche mining bei bitcoin ist ja
unter anderem dass man transaktion bitcoin kenner korrigiert mich wenn ich
falsch liege das eigentliche meinig oder das was was über bitcoin macht ist ja
quasi du sicherst mit deinem meinig die transaktion irgendwie ab und dafür
bekommst du dann als belohnung quasi in den anteil von bitcoins wenn du da was
bei steuerst ja irgendwie so muss sie irgendwie so ist das
singe kuro 22 monate hyper subscription exzellente subs hier die stabilität und
so weiter bei schia ist es jetzt so das wird als warum heißt das eigentlich
nicht kia sowie china beworben da ist es so man benutzt nicht mehr dieses proof
of work konzept sondern ein proof of space konzept und wenn man sich das mal
so ganz oberflächlich anschaut dann steht dass man quasi festplatten
speicherplatz oder allgemeinen speicherplatz zur verfügung stellt und
über diesen speicherplatz wird eben ich sag mal diese arbeit verrichtet dass
die sicherheit in der blockchain gewährleistet und das ganze ist aber
nicht ganz so einfach ich habe das jetzt eine woche für euch ausprobiert um zu
schauen wie funktioniert das ganze sowohl im positiven als auch negativen
sind also wie kann man das machen wenn man so unbedingt machen möchte und was
sind tatsächlich die auswirkungen davon und was steckt so ein bisschen mehr
dahinter als einfach nur ich schieb eine datei auf eine festplatte den ganz so
einfach ist es in der realität nämlich nicht dieses video wird unterstützt von
korsett heißt das nummer dass ich das richtig verstehe heißt es jetzt durch
durch schia werden festplatten auch übelst teuer ich hoffe ja nicht
oh nee alter was soll ich bald für den pc bezahlen sind schon fack was soll ich
bald für den pc bezahlen kann ich moment müssen es lokale festplatten
sein oder kann ich auch cloud speicher verwenden
komponenten über den link in der beschreibung kommt ihr zum sortiment von
hydro x und auch zum sehr hilfreichen cooling konfigurator wenn ihr euch mal
nicht sicher seid welche komponenten und radiatoren ihr verbauen könnt seid ihr
da auf jeden fall an der richtigen adresse am moment ist es sehr laut
erst mal das gehäuse auswählen wie zum beispiel exzellenzell aus anschließend
auswahl der benötigten teilen wie zum beispiel xd7 rgb was ich gerade dabei bin
wenn der bauer sellout macht macht mal ausrufezeichen hetzner im chat wer auf
der suche ist nach dem 20 euro gutscheincode xd5 pumpe empfohlene
anschlüsse und radiatoren inklusive montage position also probiert es einfach
mal aus und schaut euch an wie ihr eure persönliche wasserkühlung konfigurieren
könnte ihr kennt ja noch unsere guten amd reisen langzeit test setups die
laufen ja sowieso dachte ich mir für bestandskunden geht es leider nicht
auch noch diese seagate extra strife das sind 16 terabyte hdds die habe ich mir
eigentlich für mein eigenes nas mal gekauft das heißt ich habe noch leute
leute ich habe noch 30 terabyte ich habe noch 30 terabyte hier rum liegen
unbenutzt kann ich damit jetzt big big money schia meinen oder was also dachte
ich mir ok wenn diese setups so laufen müssen um den langzeit test durchzuführen
übrigens laufen die sehr sehr gut also bisher konnte ich keinerlei negative
einflüsse sage ich mal feststellen so als kurzes update zu diesem thema ich
habe jetzt eine woche aus dem testlub rausgenommen
ihr seht das linke läuft auch gerade gar nicht aber generell konnte ich
zumindest mal bei den cpus was die lebenserwartung betrifft noch gar
nichts feststellen aber das behandeln wir natürlich dann wenn es soweit ist in
einem extra video nichtsdestotrotz habe ich dann hier eben meine setups so ein
bisschen abgewandelt ihr seht ich habe dann eine mp 600 hier reingebaut und auch
auf dem rechten ist dann hier unter diesem schild da rechts ist noch mal eine
mp 600 drin und dann eben die hdds angeschlossen um das ganze für euch
auszuprobieren aber wie genau funktioniert dieses
schia farming jetzt letztendlich also es ist nicht einfach so dass man seine hdd
nimmt packt dann ein paar files drauf und dann läuft es ganz so einfach ist es
ok jetzt bin ich mal gespannt denn diese files die wir da drauf packen müssen
quasi uns schia kalkulator moment moment moment das muss man kurz
sack sack muss das muss man gucken der schia kalkulator
was sind dann plots terabyte
ja 27 terabyte
was der fuck
warum bekomme ich da 2000 dollar im monat für
ok jetzt bin ich mal gespannt die haben eine typische größe wenn sie mal auf
der hdd landen von 100 gigabyte während dem plotting prozess haben die eine
größe von bis zu 240 gigabyte und der plotting prozess der dauert auch
ziemlich lange schauen wir uns gleich drüben beim system an
letztendlich funktioniert es so dass unser plot quasi ist wie ein los und
wenn wir glück haben also wir packen das alles in den los top rein genauso wie
alle anderen ihre plots in diesen los top rein packen und dann werden da die
ganze zeit glück spiel auf quitsch ist nicht verboten mittlerweile glück hat
ist eben sein los dabei das bedeutet je mehr lose wir reinschmeißen des zu
größe ist unsere chance dass wir gezogen werden wir unseren koin gewinnen
letztendlich ist aber das problem dass in den topf die ganze zeit rein werfen
und dementsprechend weiter aktiv plotten sinkt unsere wahrscheinlichkeit das zu
gewinnen so sieht das ganze jetzt aus wenn man ok ok das heißt das heißt
man braucht auch noch eine gute cpu dafür
was auch immer hinter plotten steckt also wir sehen hier unten diese ganzen
plots also dass hier unten sind alles die ich quasi schon gedruckt habe mit
der ssd und hier oben haben wir dann und machts einen unterschied wie schnell das
ist also ist eine ssd besser als eine platte vorgängigen wir sind die sind
jetzt gerade so bei 9 bis 10 prozent und so ein plot dauert je nachdem was ihr
für hardware verwendet sage ich mal zwischen 5 und vielleicht sogar 10 oder
15 stunden wo okay einen einzelnen plot und dieser plotting prozess der ist
eben letztendlich unser limitierender faktor weil er dauert sehr sehr lange und
wir wollen ja so viele plots also lose wie möglich haben um letztendlich
gewinnen zu können die hdd ist dann eigentlich nur der ort wo wir das ganze
speichern also unseren los topf aber die generierung von diesen losen quasi
unserer drucke ist in dem fall die ssd und das kommt darauf an ob wir eine
sata ssd habt oder ob ihr eine ssd habt im idealfall nimmt man eben eine sehr
schnelle ssd vielleicht sogar noch im rate damit kommt man so auf sag mal um
die fünf stunden pro plot weil das problem ist wir können nicht nur
einfach ein plot machen und werfen den in den topf und dann generieren wir
infinite money so funktioniert es eben nicht weil ein einzelner plot wenn wir
das in den schiller calculator eintippen das können wir gleich mal machen also
ist das gar nicht so dass man möglichst viel braucht man braucht möglichst
schnellen speicher also am besser besser ein bisschen weniger speicher und
möglichst schnell oder nicht lange bis wir da gewinnen und die gewinnschance
ist eigentlich gar nicht vorhanden es gibt ja nämlich von schia auch den schi
calculator und da kann man dann schauen wie viele plots brauche ich um
letztendlich einen schia coin zu formen und was ist dann vielleicht letztendlich
mein ertrag ihr seht wenn ich jetzt ein einzelnen plot da links oben einstellt
dann komme ich jetzt schon bei 13 jahren raus als ich von der woche angefangen
habe da war das bei sechs jahren quasi komplett verdoppelt und jetzt mal sagen
ok wir packen jetzt so eine 18 terabyte ssd 16 terabyte ssd die ich da habe
mal komplett ach ja mal einfach so eine 16 terabyte ssd haben dann dauert es
ungefähr ein monat mit 160 plots also mit einer 16 terabyte hdd dann weil ich
kauf ich kauf mir einfach schia coin easy da muss ich nicht selbst mal es ist
nicht gegeben dass man nach einem monat auch wirklich gewinnt und letztendlich
plotten ja aktiv alle anderen auch weiter das heißt diese zeit wird weiter
ansteigen wenn man danach aufhört das bedeutet letztendlich wir sind eigentlich
dauerhaft darauf angewiesen zu plotten also wenn jetzt jemand sagt ich habe
einen terabyte frei auf meiner hdd dann kann man dieses thema definitiv gleich
lassen die chance dann einen coin jemals zu bekommen ist quasi gleich null und
wenn man dann sagt ok ich habe jetzt keine ahnung 50 terabyte an hdd speicher
rumliegen und möchte das gerne füllen dann ist man eben letztendlich durch den
plotting prozess beschränkt weil er dauert wie gesagt für einen plot ja
circa fünf stunden im besten fall man kann zwar mehrere parallel machen aber
auch nicht unbegrenzt viele weil man dann auch durch den arbeitsspeicher
beschränkt ist durch die cpu rechenleistung und letztendlich und das ist
einer der größten knackpunkte die ssd lebensdauer
wie bereits erwähnt habe ich korsair mp 600 ssd ist ein lauter also ganz neu ihr
seht hier ein terabyte in der größe rechts unten sehen wir auch dass die
estimer gestartet wurde läuft jetzt 123 stunden insgesamt und oben drüber steht
total host rights sind wir jetzt bei circa 50.000 gigabyte die lebensdauer von
so eine ssd wird die ist relativ zackig stand vorbei angegeben also in
terabytes written bedeutet wie viele terabyte kann ich auf diese ssd zumal
zumal die halt nicht einfach nur nur
du schreibst ja auch komplett den ganzen tag über das ist dann doch schon
relativ schnell schnell weg diese ssd kaputt ist bei so nur mp 600 liegen wir
bei 1800 tbw also es ist schon eine der echt guten ssd ist weil ich sag mal wenn
er eine günstigere ssd gekauft hat vielleicht mit nur 500 gigabyte in der
richtung dann gibt es ganz ganz viele consumer ssds die liegen zwischen 150
und 300 bis 400 tbw was im normalen alltagsbetrieb locker ja da kommt ihr
wahrscheinlich zehn jahre meine ich habe mal geguckt die erste samsung ssd die
ich mir gekauft habe das war eine 256 g sata ssd ich habe letztens mal wieder
den ollen rechner angemacht also den habe ich schon zwei jahren drei jahre
nicht mehr eingeschaltet die hat heute noch 98 prozent lebensdauer
alles ganz ganz entspannt allerdings habe ich mir jetzt mal angeschaut wie
schreibintensiv ist das plotten denn eigentlich weil im ersten moment denkt
man so okay das sind 100 gigabyte datei kann ja gar nicht so krass sein
allerdings habe ich dann drei plots gemacht einfach nur damit man so ein
bisschen genau das ergebnis hat mittelwert gibt eine ssd eine warnung
bevor sie stirbt das kommt drauf an also wenn da wirklich hardware technisch
von heute auf morgen was kaputt geht dann nicht du kannst halt die lebensdauer
also die den den du hast ja du hast ja zwei sachen du hast einmal diesen wert
den sie den die einzelnen zellen schaffen und du hast diese anzeige wie
viele zellen übrig sind und du hast ja dann auch noch den den zusätzlichen
back ab wie nennt man den also das was normalerweise gar nicht beschrieben
wird was bonus obendrauf sind bei so einer ssd und du kannst die lebensdauer da
schon monitoren natürlich kann die ssd auch in den hardware fehler haben und
von heute auf morgen kaputt gehen aber nachdem ssd keine beweglichen teile
drin haben ist der chance ist die chance bei einer festplatte höher dass die
einfach mal den geist drauf gibt
bei drei plots ergibt dass wir pro plot 1328 gigabyte schreibleistung haben und
das ist wirklich ordentlich also 1,3 tbw pro plot gehen flöten und bei der mp 600
ist es jetzt nicht so wild weil die hat wie gesagt 1800 tbw bedeutet wir haben
circa aktuell mit 50.000 gigabyte die wir verbraucht haben circa drei prozent
der lebensdauer eingeschränkt innerhalb von einer woche bei der cause mp 600 also
das kann man jetzt ein paar wochen machen und die mp 600 hält trotzdem noch eine
weile hätte man jetzt aber so eine günstige rey consumer ssd vielleicht mit
qlc speicher zum beispiel ja dann hätte man nach einer woche jetzt mal locker ein
drittel der lebenserwartung von der ssd weggebraten und es ist dann schon krass
das bedeutet man kann einfach drei bis vier wochen plotten und dann ist die
ssd dead und das finde ich schon ziemlich ziemlich krass
übrigens habe ich jetzt nach der knapp ein woche also sind sechs tage ungefähr
habe ich jetzt einen plot count von 49 stück und er sagt mir ich könnte einen
chia coin in circa drei monaten erhalten also sieht oben drüber aktuell habe ich
noch gar nichts bekommen und habe da ungefähr sechs terabyte an materiale
hier liegen nachdem wir dann klar geworden ist wie groß der einfluss das
heißt ssd's werden fucking teuer jetzt ja von diesem ganzen schreibprozess habe
ich mich dann gefragt wie kann man das ganze vielleicht beschleunigen
verbessern wie auch immer da bin ich auf die idee mit ram disk gekommen
ram disk ja ok arbeitsspeicher riegel nehmen oder ein dann wird ram auch noch
teuer hör mal auf ram war die ganze zeit so billig jetzt mit ram auch noch
teuer die simuliere darauf ein laufwerk also es gibt ja schon ganz lange das
haben wir schon bei windows xp damals gemacht das problem ist natürlich an
dieser geschichte was ist dann bald nicht mehr teuer cpu bald ist die cpu das
billigste beim rechner cpu gibt es genug grafikkarte teuer ram teuer ssd teuer
festplatte teuer was kommt als nächstes netzwerk teuer jetzt wird auch noch ram
teuer meine güne du kannst ja wahrscheinlich in den nächsten fünf
jahren ein rechner verkaufen ein plot mit 101 gigabyte letztendlicher größe
brauchen wir zwischendurch bis zu 240 gigabyte und wo hat man denn mal bitte
kurz 240 gigabyte an arbeitsspeicher frei das hat man nicht um einfach mal
nicht unbedingt zu erstellen consumer hardware generell gar nicht weil wir
bräuchten über also wir bräuchten eigentlich 512 gigabyte speicher um das
realisieren zu können weil ich muss mal den felix fragen ob wir nicht noch
alte server haben die haben so um die 2 terabyte ram da machen wir einfach ich
das ist eine idee gleich mal montag den felix anruf wir machen einfach schia
mining auf alten servoren bei uns für den plotting prozess selbst speicher
wir brauchen für unser betriebssystem arbeitsspeicher und dann eben mindestens
240 gigabyte ram disk also kein problem einfach nach stundenabrechnung online
ein server gemietet dual epic 7402 also 224 kerne epic 512 gigabyte arbeitsspeicher
reingebracht das ist das was ich mir auch überlegt hat man könnte sich
einfach mal einen cloudserver mieten problem kann man mal kurz machen remote
desktop verbindung hergestellt und dann haben wir über ubuntu mal auf einer ram
disk geplottet und es funktioniert es ist sogar minimal schneller als auf einer
ssd minimal es ist wirklich nicht viel wir haben das mal gegen gerechnet wir
kommen da knapp unter fünf stunden wenn man das ein bisschen optimiert also im
besten fall ist man vielleicht zehn prozent schneller als mit einer ssd ich
vermute mal wenn man vier ssd ist im nvm e rate macht dann sind die ssd
letztendlich trotzdem noch schneller als die ram disk allerdings stirbt die ram
disk nicht nur das problem ist wir können nur einen einzelnen plot
gleichzeitig machen weil wir haben nicht so viel speicherplatz wir bräuchten über
ein terabyte arbeitsspeicher um da mehrere plots also zum beispiel drei plots
parallel laufen zu lassen und dann wäre es uns selber so
unfassbar teuer dass ich das stimmt aber wie ist es mit ssd auf jeden fall
mein freund wenn wir gucken gerade mal kurz
was würden so ein cloudserver cloudserver kosten mit mit ram mit nicht
mit ram mit mit ssd speicher man kann extra storage hallo
jetzt noch blies
ah k pricing
storage hier
ok dann reicht ja das kleine nimmer die die kleinste vier kern cpu
ach so moment können sie können so nicht rechnen ja ist gut
die webseite ist langsam so ok prices was kostet ssd preise
ok das wird sich theoretisch rechnen das wird sich theoretisch rechnen oder
du bezahlst für 10 terabyte ssd wahrscheinlich in der praxis nicht weil
die ssd nicht den speed haben den man vielleicht bräuchte
ich meine du kannst theoretisch noch mehr server nehmen mit ssd ist
na kannst du einfach was ist denn wenn du was ist denn wenn du wenn du zwei server
sind wir brauchen einfach an peter bei dann haben ein 17 kommen peter bald haben
ein monat ich glaube trotzdem nicht dass ich das wirklich lohnt es kommt auf den
speed an der ssd ist die man bekommt und wahrscheinlich weiß ich nicht ob die
ob die das auf dauer mitmachen die ssd ist durch brennt quasi
keine option wir haben es ausprobiert es ist ein bisschen schneller nicht so
schnell dass es sich lohnt und für die kosten die man für sonen selber
gestieren müsste keine chance aber wie sieht die ganze geschichte aus wenn man
sagt alles klar ist mir alles egal ich möchte trotzdem schia farmen und wie
mache ich das jetzt am besten ohne dass mein ganzes system direkt drauf geht
als basis habe ich mich für einem die threadl bei entschieden weil diese
plattform einfach unfassbar viel kerne und gleichzeitig sehr sehr viele lanes
bietet was für unsere dezente ansammlung das wird teuer sehr gut sein
wird cpu habe ich mir ein 930 60 x gekauft also 24 kerner das sollte auf
jeden fall ausreichen man könnte ja auch ein 930 70 x nehmen oder auch sogar ein
39 90 x falls man das unbedingt braucht aber ich denke das sollte ausreichen
ja und dafür habe ich mir auch noch eine riesen armada an ssd gekauft und zwar
diese wiper vpn 100 pc express drives zwei terabyte pro nvm e ssd die
namen die namen von hardware mittlerweile mal kurz besprochen dass wir
ungefähr 1,3 terabyte pro plot brauchen und wir ungefähr die beste hardware
benahmung hatte immer noch meine alte grafikkarte meine meine 980 t.i.
ja ich wünsche ich schill ich schill ich schill 980 dera dera
ino 3d geforce gtx 980 i chill x4 airboss ultra moment die der name war
eigentlich noch länger der moment mein der name war noch länger der name war
noch länger da war doch hercules irgendwie mit drinne
als der hercules x4 airboss ultra ja
als den herkules x4 airbos ultra
Hast du nicht in 980 ti ne ich hab eine 1080 ti
Die hatte ich hier davor
Aber warum sind die seiten gerade so übelst übelst lahm
Ok das war den das war den selbst zu dumm der name dass die haben die kürzer kürzer gemacht
Ja die sieht die sieht echt hässlich aus
Ja äh wie auch immer
Hinten bekommen von der geschwindigkeit her wenn man das alles mal so ausrechnet dann reicht so eine ssd für circa 600 tage plotten und das ist dann tatsächlich ganz ordentlich also gute zwei jahre fast zwei jahre kommt man mit diesen ssd hin also wenn man da die richtigen nimmt dann geht es auch ich bastel das ganze jetzt mal zusammen hoffe das funktioniert alles so wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder einer der gründe warum ich mich für dieses bord hier entschieden habe ist die lieferumfang dabei es gibt
Die geballt war so nett und hat mir noch eine zweite geschickt
Das ist aber nett
Aber auf dieser erweiterungskarte können wir vier m2 ssds noch mal drauf packen das bord hat ja generell schon relativ viele m2 ssds hier drunter aber ich finde es für so ein projekt auf jeden fall angenehmer wenn wir die in erweiterungskarten haben beziehungsweise wir könnten natürlich hier zusätzlich noch mehr reinpacken hier packen wir ja einen fürs betriebssystem drauf und dann hätten wir noch mal zwei extra weiter frei
Wir haben ja bei den wiper vpn 100 kühler schon drauf das bedeutet ich werde das offen lassen werde das einfach hier drauf machen wir haben lüfter der fächer so ein bisschen luft drüber wenn man ssds hat die keinen kühler haben dann ist das eigentlich auch ganz cool weil bei dieser karte ist ja so ein echt krasser kupferblock mit dabei mit einem riesen wärmelite pad das drückt dann hier drauf geht dann hier schön luftstrom drüber und dann werden moment sehe ich das richtig das ist ein aktiv ein aktiv kühler für ssds
wo wir 2021 schon angekommen sind ich meine man darf nicht vergessen asus oder asus hat monitore mit lüfter drin mittlerweile
fangen zu throttlen wenn die zu warm werden weil beim plotten da werden die schon warm da sind die schon gut unter last und das werden wir mit so einer karte hier mit dieser belüftung auf jeden fall verhindern ist auch besser als wenn es einfach nur unter so einer kleinen passiven heat sink hier sitzt im idealfall habt ihr dann übrigens auch noch sowas hier das ist eine gt 710 mit pc express x1 und die klaut uns so deutlich weniger pc express lanes rein theoretisch gibt es sogar m2 adapter wo man dann das heil eigentlich einen m2 slot anschließen kann
das würde tatsächlich hier ist es umgedreht hier willst du pc express lanes sparen dass deine ssd schneller sind das hat schon was das sieht ja das hat man dieses system läuft jetzt rgb wo ist rgb gemacht ich habe auch noch einen drifter drauf gelegt also ich meine allein schon für noch mehr extra boost muss da noch ein bisschen rgb drauf da hier da die ssd in rate gepackt immer zweierpaare habe sie jetzt aber einzelnen daufen das scheint mir erst
mal die schnellere lösung zu sagen ein bisschen rgb rein gepackt jetzt aktuell 64 gigabyte 3600 megahertz sowohl kapazität als auch geschwindigkeit scheinen bei dieser geschichte zu helfen in der konfiguration können wir jetzt aktuell 16 plots gleichzeitig machen das ist schon ganz ordentlich dauert aber nach wie vor circa sechs bis sieben stunden pro plot weil man natürlich auch letztendlich in der arbeitsspeichermenge begrenzt ist in dem fall 64 gigabyte da könnte ich mal meinen surferraum für was sinnvolles verwenden sehen es zwar dass wir gerade mal 30
gigabyte benötigt werden aber es kommt auch darauf an in welchem abschnitt sich das plotting gerade befindet ich habe gesehen so zwischen 20 und 30 prozent da braucht es fast die doppelte menge an arbeitsspeicher was man aber deutlich sehen kann ist dass auch hier die cpu und ich meint es ist ein 24 kenner der ist da schon ganz schön wobei leute ich weiß ohne scheiß ich könnte das echt machen ich habe doch genau die passende hardware für hier guck doch mal
warte mal ich habe doch genau die richtige hardware dafür wo habe ich denn das video hier surferraum 2021 ja guck mal ich habe doch gedacht ich habe doch meine alte kiste hier noch das sind zwar nur acht kerne
acht kerne aber ich habe volle pizzi express things
sass anschlüsse 8 8 8 sass anschlüsse das ist eigentlich wie gemacht dafür
und ich habe glaube und ich habe glaube 48 g ram drinne ich mache das nicht aber man könnte es damit gut machen
ist auch hier in hardware info cpu package power an die cpu zieht durchgehend hier ihre 200 das kommt
stromkosten auch noch dabei schon nicht gerade ohne was haben wir jetzt nach einer woche schier
farming gelernt schier nennt das ganze er farming und ich meine auch wenn es für mich eigentlich so
ziemlich das gleiche ist man stellt sich bei schier ja auch so sage ich mal sehr umweltfreundlich da
alles ist so grün die sein ja ja genau wie ein paper nicht weit paper wo die ganzen details drin
stehen und so weiter da ist die frage gibt es eine grüne kryptowährung aus meiner sicht ist das
definitiv nicht der fall wir sehen das als beispiel an diesem system hier weil letztendlich bei solchen
geschichten dreht sich immer ums welt umweltfreundlich bedeutet in dem fall nicht ganz so schlecht wie die
anderen weiß ich nicht ob das umweltfreundlich durchgeht es wollen viele leute geld verdienen
und dann wird es so eskalieren wie in diesen bitcoin farmen wo dann zehntausende grafikkarten rumstehen
da wird es genauso sein dann eben halt mit ssd s und hard drives und man sieht ja an diesem
system das zieht letztendlich ungefähr 350 watt dauerhaft aus der steckdose und wir können
ich ohne ich sage mal 40 bis 60 plots am tag machen also ist schon ordentlich was man damit auf
jeden fall machen kann wenn man dann in den schier calculator geht dann kann man mit dem wenn man
genug festplatten speicherplatz hat in der theorie zumindest aktuell locker um die 3000 4000
euro im monat machen also laut calculator also es würde sich auf jeden fall rechnen
rein theoretisch würde sich dieses system in einem monat selbst ungefähr finanzieren ich kann
das selber jetzt erstmal nicht bestätigen weil ich nach einer woche kein einzigen coin gefarbt
habe weil es natürlich auch eine mathematische wahrscheinlichkeit ist deswegen kann ich jetzt
nur nach dem calculator gehen ich wollte aber vor allem betrachten wie wirkt sich das ganze
zum beispiel auf die ssd lebenszeit aus und ist das ganze auch wirklich so krass wie viele
hersteller das online vielleicht bemängelt haben die wollen natürlich nicht dass dann die ganzen
ssd sterben und die alles ersetzen müssen das haben die natürlich immer als hersteller im
hinterkopf das muss man immer betrachten wenn ein hersteller eine aussage trifft dann ist es
natürlich immer ultra 93 das haben wir schon geguckt dass dann immer der realität entspricht
das muss man selber betrachten wir haben gesehen wenn man eine ssd hat mit einer sehr geringen
schreibleistung also hat man eine günstige ssd gekauft mit vielleicht 150 300 tbw dann ist es
möglich mit schia farming tatsächlich eine ssd in einem monat komplett zu ruinieren das ist safe
möglich wenn man allerdings weiß was man da tut und weiß alles klar ich möchte es jetzt hier mit
diesem system ein jahr lang machen und packt sich solche ssd ist wie hier die wiper drauf ist das
kein problem es gibt viele ssd ist die sowas problemlos abkönnen ob das ist die wiper ist
die mp 600 genauso die hat jetzt eben ihre drei prozent ich hab bloß kein bock dass jetzt auch
noch ram und ssd ist teuer werden dadurch und fest und das ist dann eben auch nicht viel also
die kann man da auch ein jahr lang durchlaufen lassen dementsprechend ist es nicht so dass man
das laufen lässt und dann ist sofort alles kaputt man braucht ja auch den entsprechenden
festplattenspeicherplatz um das letztendlich da drauf abzulegen und wer das zu hause macht und
dann seine zehn stunden da mal plottet und legt da irgendwas auf eine hdd ab und lässt es da für
zwei jahre rumdümpeln bei dem wird es safe nicht die ssd ruinieren also wie gesagt so ein bisschen
differenziert betrachten ob das ist wirklich so krass ist oder nicht also es ist definitiv möglich
ssd ist kaputt zu machen aber halt eben nur wenn man schlechte hat die dafür nicht gemacht war
und wenn man weiß dass man tut und das richtige equipment kauft ist es definitiv kein problem was
ich aber auch sagen möchte ist aus meiner sicht gibt es so was wie eine grüne kriptowährung
das hat er recht es ist bloß ein bisschen weniger schlimm und natürlich auch zu übermäßigen
stromverbrauch bei weil die leute die das dann im großen stil machen und dann vielleicht hunderte
solche systeme aufsetzen das führt zu zusätzlich enormen stromverbrauch das kann mir keiner sagen
dass es nicht so wäre also grün einfach nur hier was auf festwarte ablegen so ist das aus meiner
sicht in der realität einfach nicht weil man dauerhaft plotten muss um dabei zu bleiben um eine
relativ hohe chance hat was abzugreifen ok damit hoffe ich das video hat euch gefallen war ein
bisschen was anderes ich bedanke mich fürs zuschauen macht es gut bis dahin ja es ist
interessant zu sehen ich meine ich könnte es ich meine ich könnte das schon mit der kiste
hier machen aber ich zeige sie nachher noch mal ja ich meine das könnte man mit der kiste
schon machen ich meine ich habe massig sade anschlüsse anschlüsse ich habe noch das komplette
pizzi express zeug ist leer doch guter content für youtube ja aber ich will nicht erst mal
3000 euro noch mal ausgeben für dass ich gut machen kann ich brauche ich würde halt die ssd
brauchen was kosten so die nein nee das schwachsinn das mache ich nicht was kosten schia koin gerade
so nicht schenkein schia koin nicht schenkein schi ja was zum kurz das da das das richtige
ok das stagniert jetzt schon sein moment das ist auch guck mal ok das ist nicht hier to the
moon das ach das ist noch gar nicht so lang guck mal das ist ja erst seit vier tagen
ich auch mal ganz ordentlich eine güte was nicht alles gibt aber bald aber bald kannst
du doch echt nichts mehr kaufen ram teuer ssd teuer festplatten teuer cpus teuer grafikkarten
extrem teuer willst du dann für mittelklasse rechner 6000 euro ausgeben oder wie das ist
wollte ich gerade sagen für pc gaming ist das ja auch nicht gut naja worst hold music ever
das stimmt das habe ich vorhin angeguckt das war das war lustig das ist wirklich die mit
abstand wirklich ohne scheiß die mit abstand schlechteste warte musik beim telefon was
ich je gehört habe weil euch das waren ich mache absichtlich nicht so laut ja weil die
sind ganz eklig das ist so schlecht
das hört sich an hast du irgendwie so die gruppe aus dem kindergarten die random auf
ihren instrumenten bläst es ist wirklich hardcore schlecht ja das ist wenn du die leute loswerden
willst ist schon gut ja ich habe da gar nichts raus richtig schlecht ok youtube noch mal
eine chance also gutes video zu empfehlen lockpicking lawyer ok hey das ist meine collectors edition
die was ausgeliefert haben erinnert sich noch einer an die cola von fallout 76 ne fallout
70 wie ist das ding die cola und die tasche von fallout 76
it would seem that the marketers of the game appreciated the irony of including a bank
security device with the game that prominently features bank robbery now i've opened a whole
lot of similar bank and document pouches before but this one actually surprised me with a
wafer core that took some skill to open that's likely because the heavy spring loading on
the core makes finding the correct tension a challenge even so it's good for you nicht
er wackelt zweimal und es ist auf so let's give it a shot
er sagt mal wäre es nicht besser das einfach aufzuschneiden anstatt das schloss zu knacken
bottom of the keyway tension with this wiper insert we're going to have to put a fair bit
of torque on that core then to pick the wafers going to use a standard hook in 25000s
okay little click on one binding binding on two three five okay six is binding binding six binding
click on five click on four nothing on three two or one let's work our way to the back
nothing on two just touch three and we dropped into a bit of a false set probably just one
wafer holding us up okay okay er braucht schon länger als sonst das scheint gar nicht schlecht
zu sein dass das gimmick schloss ist besser als die meist andere schlosser die da so hat
my pick along i can feel it's probably number six and we got this open okay folks as you
saw that didn't take too long but that heavy spring loading really makes this wafer lock punch above
its weight in any case ich mein mit messer aufschneiden hier die die tasche ist wahrscheinlich
einfacher als zu picken aber er ist er ist ja nicht da der taschen aufschneiden leuer sondern
der lockpicking leuer da wird auch gepickt like this video and would like to see more like it
please subscribe and as always excellent so was haben wir hier als nächstes reale irrsinn
corona oh nee nee das halte ich jetzt nicht aus
die tasche ist online multiplayer on gameboy hau cpu in 100 sekunden alles klar easy
100 sekunden in zwölf minuten aber das macht er öfters was haben wir sonst noch hier zu
bieten was die digitale zerstörung der cdu da habe ich vor schon ein bisschen durchgeblendet
dass es mir jetzt zu harte kost seid ihr vom facebook datenleak betroffen jetzt schadensersatz
fordern okay leute easy habt ihr habt ihr auch die habt ihr auch die scam sms gekriegt
was diese tasche ist genial soll ich mir anschauen ok copy link alles klar wenn der chat das sagt
dann ich manchmal höre ich ja auf den chat wetten wetten ist es nicht slash resistant
das ist nicht slash resistent es ist fast wertlos als ein sicherheitsgericht
er weiß nicht er hat kritische Informationen zu testen wie slash resistent es wirklich ist
ich werde meinen täglichen carry pocket knife für den test benutzen und weil ich weiß, dass
ihr alle in den kommenten fragt, ist der Macher off-grid das schneidet wahrscheinlich einmal
ist es auf oder ich werde einen Link in der Beschreibung unten jetzt, weil die Sicherheit
eines Produktes ist durch die weichste Linke definiert, werde ich alle Seiten der Tasche
wie auch die Schraube testen, wenn sich jeder von ihnen leichter schneiden kann, werde ich es als
Fail betrachten, also lassen wir uns das aus dem Packagier und sehen, wie es klappt wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich ist die Tasche schnittfest aber du kannst wahrscheinlich hier oben einfach abschneiden
oder so ok ich denke wir starten mit der Tasche ok das wird sehr einfach und ich denke das wird
wahrscheinlich am Ende für das aber lasst uns weiter testen und ich denke wir schneiden die
top next slash resistent huge slash resistent ok ok es hat zwei seiten die sind slash resistent
alle anderen seiten kannst du einfach aufschneiden das ist natürlich äußerst sinnvoll
das ist so schlecht selbst da wo angeblich nicht fest ist kann man durchschneiden
ist es schlecht ist das schlecht ist das schlecht meine güte ist es april scherz
ok das schloss muss er überhaupt nicht ran ja das hilft gegen so messer die kinder bei
fasching dabei haben ok jetzt lassen wir uns mal erklären ich will kein schadensatz aber jetzt
wo ich das video sehe habt ihr auch dieses gem sms bekommen mit ihr paket ist da ihr paket ist da
klicken sie hier das kommt ja aus dem facebook aus dem facebook leak zum größten teil
das hat fast jeder irgendwie bekommen wobei ich sagen muss ich habe meine
handynummer glaub gar nicht bei facebook wie können die es dann haben
vielleicht habe ich dir doch dahinter liegen müssen damals keine super projekt falls du es
nicht kennst das haben wir sogar hier auf hier guck mal online multiplayer on gameboy das gucken
wir jetzt exzellent big brain content massive content wie sie leise
ok ich muss ich muss laut das
wenn ich den sound hier so laut machen dann ist auch meine emotes auf einmal so laut so laut
habt ihr so nie gehört hier ich bin ja auch dumm ich bin richtig dumm ich hätte vielleicht den
sound lauter machen sollen anstatt hier umzustellen
leute niemand von uns hat multiplayer tetris auf dem gameboy gespielt also ich vielleicht ich bin
ja auch boomer also ich habe es gespielt das war noch vor das war richtig nice so ein habe
ich auch so logic analyzer genau den auch mit vier inputs genau den habe ich auch richtig
nice ist da
p2p hosting es verfolgt uns seit dem gameboy warum hatten die keine dedicated server damals
was soll das nintendo nintendo und online selbst damals schon nix
ok naja es muss ja alles für battle royale sein wobei letztens hat nintendo doch bei
der switch sogar nen tetris battle royale released aber nintendo online ist ja nintendo
darf man nicht vergessen und das ist jetzt glaube ich nicht mehr im shop drinne das video
provides basic match creation and match management functionality using this architecture on game
boys can talk to the same game server the game server on game start will send the same tiles
to all other clients eventually all but one game boy will either fill up and win or someone
finishes the 30 lines first and wins that way now in my last video i already used the
raspberry pi pico combined with some level shifters and a modified link cable to connect
the game boy to my computer this is not something you can send to your friends and it also was
not really used or particularly stable and so i decided to design a custom pcb that has
the level shifters and the raspberry pi pico on board it's much easier to handle and doesn't
require cutting open a link cable because it has the link cable connectors directly on
board it is also both compatible with the original gameboy connector as well as well
as the gameboy color of the gameboy pocket color and the advance and advance sp on the
other side we have a raspberry pi pico that provides all the logic and usb functionality
i am also excited hey das ist das erste anwendungsding wo ich mal das sinnvoll finden raspberry
pi pico zu verwenden ich mein allein schon für usb in dem fall ja man könnte auch ein
esp 32 s2 oder so nehmen aber das ist tatsächlich mal eine anwendung wo ich sinnvoll finden
diesen diesen raspberry pi microcontroller zu verwenden ansonsten fehlt dem ding ja so
gut wie alles von wireless bis bluetooth was normalerweise interessant macht
ich habe letztens ein video gesehen von einem der hat seine smd komponenten mit einem bügeleisen
gelötet like i did here this allows you to experiment with the link cable protocol yourself
and to play tetris against your friends over the internet you can find the link to order
one in the description alternatively you can also sacrifice das da oben sieht aus gläute
das da oben sieht ohne scheiß sieht aus wie so ein feuerwerkskörper wie irgendwie wie
irgendwie so ein so ein böller the couple of level shifters and a breadboard to build
your own adapter i'll put some instructions for that into the github repository for the
firmware i wanted to try something i hadn't used before web usb i wanted to make usage
of the adapter as simple as possible without having to deal with building drivers for different
operating web usb without having to deal with building a cross platform application for
windows linux and macOS and web usb allows me to do just that when you plug in the device
you get a small pop-up and when you click it das ist ein ding alter leute es gibt nichts
was browser heute nicht mehr können oder web usb habe ich ja im leben noch nichts von
gehört and that website immediately allows you to start playing no driver installation
no downloads nothing you click connect and your browser starts talking to the gameboy
aber eine coole idee what's also really awesome using web usb the adapter can even work on
android phones as always the link to the github repository with the code of the firmware is
in the description now i'm not particularly into web development but a lot of people seem
to like react so i decided to learn a bit of react development and build a simple frontend
that makes creating and joining a match super simple react the website you click connect
select the gamelink adapter and the website will then automatically connect to your gameboy
next the web interface allows you to choose your tune obviously music a is the only acceptable
choice but if you want to you can also select one of the other melodies or turn music off
entirely next you can choose a username and either create a new match or join an existing
match using a match code when you create a new match that's a really cool project that
you can send to your friends 2 somehow everyone is connected 2 let's end ich reichlich sinnlos
es gibt genug möglichkeiten multiplayer tetris zu spielen aber auf originalen gameboy über
link kabel ich mein allein schon weil es geht ist das cool simply click start to start the
game but before we try that we need to talk about the game server the game server is written
in python 3 and to allow our browser application python hipster leute wieder web sockets the
web sockets api is relatively simple and so for example we can ask the server to create
a match and will simply reply to us with a match id all other players that want to join
your game will ask the server to join the match using the match id if the match is found
and not already in progress all players will be put into a common lobby when the lobby
creator starts the game the server will send the same tileset to all players in the lobby
and the react client will then send them to the gameboy from then on the clients will
report whether they won or lost and the server will distribute all the information with all
that in place it was finally time to give it a try but first i had to find a worthy
opponent and i thought who could be a better choice than my good friend and now tetris
arch nemesis live overflow hey this is live overflow and stack smashing also sent me one
of the usb to gameboy link cable adapters which means i can challenge him to a game
of tetris so now with live overflow ready as an opponent the game was on so i created
but it's a cool project code to live overflow so you can join and there he is so it's time
to start the match live overflow versus stack smashing round one go as you can see as soon
as i hit start my gameboy starts the game and so does live overflows and we are getting
exactly the same tiles you can also see that i'm a pretty terrible tetris player i had
a strong start with a quick tetris and you can see how the lines appear on live overflow
screen unfortunately i couldn't keep that up and live overflow quickly started filling
up my screen until i eventually lost all this work programming testing soldering pcb design
and so on and i lose unbelievable but wait this is just one versus one we also need to try
multiplayer something that isn't supported by the original tetris and so we created another
match this time with three players and it works we all get to play together this time
live overflow is quickly put out of the game with only night owl and me remaining but unfortunately
i lost again but wow is it fun to play all the source code for the pico the game server
and the front end is linked in the description it's also a cool version of the game online
also if you are looking for players i've created a dedicated channel for matchmaking on my
discord if you want to support my channel you can order a pcb excellent so leute und jetzt und
jetzt nachdem wir so massive big brain content geguckt haben müssen wir uns eine runde battlefield
3 top plays angucken wo habe ich es wo habe ich es yes alter was ist das für elefthead
stretch guckt euch das mal an das ist das ist 4 zu 3 gestretched auf 100 zu 5 so sieht
das aus
oah hat gehittet könnte durchaus auch set up zu einer weide weide den mache ich absichtlich
nicht lauter weil er sagt jedes mal exakt das gleiche hoffentlich nicht so viele heli
das ist immer resident sleeper
ob es auch erstmal mit dem mit dem rotor durch das rohr
wieder ok ok das war klar metro rauchgranatwerfer und in
der es geschütet
moment haben wir nicht das letzte haben wir sich das letzte mal schon ne das ist neuer
killstreak mit dem smallclown schon die gegner wieder what the fuck richtig brain dead aber
nice ich meine du brauchst blöde gegner sonst kannst du sowas nicht machen oah close wäre
nicht so press gewesen hätte es geklappt
4 zu 3 was ist mit den ganzen was ist mit den leuten los ich mein jeder rechner in den
letzten 10 jahren kann bettel viel 3 in guter quali uns abspielen warum warum warum 4 zu
4 zu 3 macht hitboxen größer ernsthaft siehst aber auch weniger
die cs pro spielen das nicht wegen wegen hitboxen die cs pro spielen als erstens weil sie es
gewöhnt sind das ist wahrscheinlich das hauptsächliche und weil man sich irgendwie einreden kann
man sieht den einen pixel das der gegner besser um die ecke größer wird die hitbox dadurch
nicht siehst vielleicht besser den gegner pixel um die ecke also durch den schlitz oder
so oh wtf warum war da fünf gegner wieder hinter lande kopfbärm
bei stretch sind die gegner breiter korrekt dafür siehst du weniger drumherum
ich mein nach der logik wäre ja eine auflösung von 300 mal 200 am besten weil dann füllt
der gegner den kompletten bildschirm aus
wer was mit dem dude los?
Hoh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha
ah, das der war ein geiles, genau
ho, ho, ho, ho
häh, allhan
Kam jetzt was zur badルfhael, what the
Lull
Kam Jetzt was zu Belfill 6 Ja Ja Ja man, Man Kennt Jetzt das audio Des trailers richtig richtig Hängeblieben
Erstmal Schön Spreien in die Richtung
Also, Niemand hat Nicht Sinnvolles
Rambo Clips are coming on a metro shotgun kombi please running at you you're trying to hold them off you're trying to get as many as you can
Sometimes we will find ourselves in these positions for often
Tag
Managed to fight back that surge of enemy players day with some great moments wrecked
Morning
Oh Jetzt wird gesprayt Jetzt Jetzt wird gesprayt
Jetzt wird sie viert
Doch es wird gesprayt Jawohl
Die Lassen sich Weg Spreien
Moore alter
duckways
Reber, de festive
Oh, was der flankt der flankt ist ich habe also flanks immer pech bei mir drehen die sich in
dem moment um und killen mich mit zwei leuten die kriegen ja gar nichts geschissen
ok ich meine du brauchst blöde gegner klar sind wir uns einig
aber die haben sich wegsprayen lassen
das ist konsole oder also bei der auflöse ist es konsole und vom bildschirm abgefilmt
damals haben wir in der grafik gespielt und folge feiert das ps3 ist das
ist ps3 das schüttert der altbekannte schreibenwischer controller im
klipps using a mixture of the jet and the attack helicopter in battlefield 3 also
wenn das ein absichtlicher play war dann war das big brain also wenn er wenn er
das wollte dann war das big brain play using that tree to almost slow himself
down and then get behind the enemy check for the kill couple more coming in
and also some really really cool attack le clips that i think you're really
enjoying also das wäre messen stop jet play aller Zeiten gewesen wenn das wenn
das absicht gewesen wäre
die xbox ist kaputt beim preis camp wie zielt wollte ganz an wie zielt er denn
wenn er nicht im cockpit das bänken
alter was was geht mit den was geht mit den pilots da gerade ab wie so die
fliege auf der scheibe vom stauntherm
ok das ist aber das war ein eiser treffer zwar keine wirkliche absicht am
anfang aber trotzdem als der fag
ok da guckste aber schon ein bisschen bisschen keck weight mäßig wenn du
von dem relativ viel von der tv missile geht das wirst beim abspringen
es wird noch nie passieren also ist selten 2000 2 bin ich nie warm geworden
mit der waffe die sagt doch und alle rennen sie im rein
das ist wieder typisches bettel viel drei dinges model sport nicht richtigen
beziehungsweise die sport nicht richtig wie sie im rein rennen in your face
alle da darf nicht noch schau kennels darf nicht fehlen
immer noch weiß her
mason
ist das chinesisch
Koreanisch
Oooooh...
Das ist nice
Headshots
generell Headshots in Battlefield mit den Pistolen, das fühlt sich immer geil an.
Oh, jetzt werden sie hier weggebasht. Der Typ weiß überhaupt nicht was ihm passiert.
Schaut, geiles Play. Das ist ein geiles Play gewesen. Oh, das leckt. 12 FPS Clip.
Logitech sollte mich auch sponsoren, weil dann kann ich mir alle halbe Jahre eine neue Logitech-Tastatur kaufen,
wenn meine wieder mal kaputt geht. Also was heißt kaufen? Können sie mir eine schicken?
Der Amtrak war schon geil mit dem Granatenwerfer. Da konntest du so heftig bashen mit.
Gerade auf der Xbox, wo die Leute ja alle nicht gemoved sind, richtig?
Der streamt übrigens auch, ne? Also unter dem gleichen Namen streamt er auf Twitch.
Twitch, also falls doch irgendjemand All is Battlefield 3 sehen will auf Twitch, der spielt echt gut.
Alter, die werden ja wieder krass geschreckt, die Gegner, ey.
Der hat ja gerade irgendwie 30 Kills gemacht jetzt in der Zeit.
Echtig. Aber, also das kann man sich bei dem immer angucken, falls doch überhaupt jemand Battlefield 3 sehen will im Jahr 2021.
Leute, wir haben noch so viele Videos, die können wir doch gar nicht alle gucken. Was gucken wir noch?
Komm, wie lange bin ich denn schon on? 2.30, ich krieg langsam Hunger. Was schauen wir noch?
Eins gucken wir noch, was haben wir denn noch zu bieten? Ne, Corona hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
CPU, Zerstörer ist mir zu anscheuern, Facebook, Tetris, Hyper Tapping, okay, wir haben schon ein Tetris Video heute geguckt.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Smart Home, Gedöns, Smoking, Dings haben wir schon geguckt. Achso, das haben wir auch schon gesehen, das war Lull. Gucken wir das.
Übrigens, Tetris, Competitive Tetris, war eine lange Zeit richtiges Boomer Game. Das waren so Leute in meinem Alter, ne.
Mittlerweile kommen da jetzt auch schon die 15-jährigen Koreaner und ownen alles weg.
Mack Brecht, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Alter, was hat denn der für komische Audio?
Denn da gibt's ja nicht so viele.
Guck ich nachher, früher war das voll das Boomer, die Boomer Veranstaltung, Competitive Tetris. Mittlerweile sind da auch schon viele Jungen mit am Start.
Alter, what the fuck, wir halten hier den Controller. Guckt euch das mal an. Was ist das?
Das ist es, bis jetzt, wo ein 3. Spielstil in der Position ist, den Frey zu beitragen.
Es ist sogar schneller als Hypertappen, aber, wie DAS, es braucht keine superhumanen Fingerzüge, damit jeder es theoretisch lernen kann.
Und es braucht keine Modifikation der Controller oder deine Hände in irgendeiner Weise, also ist es komplett legal für Tournaments.
Das klingt zu gut zu sein, aber es ist tatsächlich sehr real und es gibt bereits einen Teil der Community, der es beherrscht und die Weltrekorde startet.
Es ist Zeit, den Raum des Rolling zu entdecken.
Rolling ist auch manchmal genannt als Fly-Hacking, weil es eine Technik aus der Art von Hector-Fly-Rodriguez auf Arcade-Tournits aus über ein Jahr.
Okay, der war damals schon Boomer. Wie zu laut.
Was? Was? Warte. Was? Was, warte, warte. Was?
ist, dass Arcade-Chemisten sehr große Knöpfe haben,
groß genug für den ganzen Finger.
Was ist denn wieder los?
... an der Seite, um herum zu gehen.
Die Knöpfe auf einem Nintendo-Controller sind klein.
Hector hatte eine Technik für schnelleren Geschwindigkeiten
auf der NES-Version von Track and Field,
die zwei Finger zurück und zurück auf den A- und B-Knöpfen entdeckte.
Aber bei NES-Tetris kann man die Teile wirklich schnell bewegen,
was nicht so nützlich ist.
Was du brauchst, ist etwas, das für den Defact funktioniert.
Interessant war, als Jonas Neubauer,
und Gitarre Rob Scallon's YouTube-Channel,
um NES-Tetris zu lernen,
war Robs erster Instinkt, eine Rolltechnik zu versuchen,
wenn man über Hypertappen erzählt wurde,
bevor er realisierte, dass es nicht wirklich funktioniert.
Als ich 7 war, hatten wir keine Hypertapper.
Ist das Hypertappen noch?
Ich kann es mir nicht sagen.
Als ich den Drum gesehen hatte,
hatten Sie viele sehr rapide, drömmende Motionen.
Ich habe mir so ein Bild gemacht.
Es ist schwer, wirklich... Es ist ein sehr kleiner D-Pad.
Ist es also ein Weg, effektiv auf dem D-Pad zu rollen?
Die D-Community experimentierte mit alternativen Hand-Positions,
die mehrere Finger an die kleinen Knöpfe bekommen.
All diese Methoden haben...
Was ist mit den Leuten los?
... komfort, Konsistenz und lang-Term-Viabilität.
V.a. und auch, wenn man sich gleichzeitig dreht.
Aber irgendwann kam ein Spieler mit einer einfachen Idee.
Statt von den Knöpfen auf dem D-Pad zu rollen
oder den Finger auf dem D-Pad zu rollen,
was ist, wenn man den ganzen Controller rollt?
Was zur Hölle?
Die Method war...
Alter, die Leute...
A cheese fish who was inspired to try rolling
while hanging out on a jakey...
Richtig Five-Hat-Time.
... when a random person in the chat had the misconception
that Jake was rolling his hand because the slow framerate...
Sekunde, ich muss meine Emotes verschieben.
Die sind immer genau über dem Controller.
Emotes müssen jetzt hier runter.
... hard to tell.
Cheese watched a YouTube tutorial on button mashing,
where a player was getting extra taps on a GameCube controller
by pushing the controller into the finger
over the buttons from the other side.
So he started trying techniques
that involved hitting the controller itself.
Cheese's grip holds his thumb still over the D-Pad
and rolls the fingers of his other hand
across the bottom of the controller.
This gives the fingers a ton more surface area to work with,
as it effectively turns the bottom of the controller
into one giant button.
It took a lot of precision to manage,
but in November 2020, he reported that with the right thumb pressure
on top of the D-Pad, he could get button pressing speeds
times per second, faster than even the fastest hypertappers
in the world.
Guckt euch das an!
The method wasn't yet reliable enough...
Das sieht aus, als spielen die Mini-Gitarre.
Guckt euch das an! The fuck?
But he kept practicing, and on December 14th, 2020,
he posted the first-ever completion of 19.5 with rolling.
And sure enough, on some of the moves,
he was reaching speeds of more than 20 hertz.
Soon, Cheese would start implementing rolling
during actual competition after reaching level 29.
And it was on full display last month during this match
versus Joseph Saley during Beast and Shen's Classic Tetris Open.
What's going on?
Ganz davon abgesehen, mein limitierender Faktor
beim Tetris-Spielen wäre nicht,
wie schnell ich die Teile nach unten bekommen kann,
sondern mein Brain wäre der limitierende Faktor,
weil ich nicht wüsste, wo ich die Teile hinpacken soll.
Dude! Oh, wir haben es verpasst!
Das ist ziemlich verrückt.
Das war sowohl der erste 1,3-Million-Test
als auch das erste Mal, dass jemand
vier Tetris über Level 29 im Wettbewerb gespielt hat.
Auch in der Zeit der Hypertappers ist das Spiel
auf dem Kill-Screen nicht normal.
Vor knapp einer Woche, am 5. April, setzte Cheese
ein New-World-Rekord für den höchsten Test auf Level 29,
mit 259.000 anfangs, und wahrscheinlich
der höchst beeindruckendste Tetris-Spiel aller Zeiten.
Am Anfang sieht sein Stack wie etwas,
das man in einem Level 19-Spiel sehen würde.
Nach 46 Lagen hat er einen langen Bar verpasst.
Er bekommt noch eine Chance und verpasst einen zweiten langen Bar,
aber er hält sich aus und erreicht, einen dritten langen Bar zu bekommen,
um den Stack zu retten und den Rund zu halten.
Nach 66 Lagen bekommt er sogar einen perfekten Clear.
Cheese hat auch seinen ersten Max-Out
mit Rollen letztes Wochenende komplett gemacht,
alles von 18 bis 29.
But this is more of just a showcase of the playstyle.
Since he's a pretty fast tapper already,
it doesn't make as much of a difference
if he's rolling on the earlier levels.
But rolling would be a huge difference for a DAS player.
Tegamec, who had the best qualifier out of all DAS players
in the 2020 CTWC, has also been learning rolling,
and he has an unusual...
Alter!
Die flippen voll aus, die Leute.
Jetzt haben wir den Tuch.
Hahahaha! Jetzt wird mit dem Fuß gedeiht.
Ich fass es nicht.
Ich fass es nicht, Alter.
Jetzt wird Haters schon mit dem Fuß gespielt.
Das ist... Da wüsste sie sich way too smart, Alter.
The usual grip where he stabilizes the controller with his foot.
Fucking Fuß! Mit dem Fuß!
He's posted videos of 19-5 attempts with peace movement
that a DAS player could only dream of.
Tegamec's videos are actually what convinced me
to try this out for myself.
Ein Fetish-Stream, ja, quasi.
Hat schon was davon.
This is another hyper-tapper trick that only they can do.
Feet-tappiger.
Oh, my gosh, maybe I can actually do this.
I did my very first stream with rolling on March 29th
and used Tegas' foot grip,
partly because I thought it was hilarious.
At first, I could barely play at all.
Ich könnte überhaupt nicht zwei Stunden so DASitzen mit dem Bein oben.
Fingers controlling the movements.
But I could see glimmers of the 20-hertz movement.
Oh, yes. Ha!
Oh, yes! It's like I've hacked into Eric's, um, hands
to get that kind of movement.
I ended up switching from Tegas' grip to Cheese's grip
because it was more comfortable for me long term.
Das ist so big brain.
And the technique has been gradually getting more viable.
Ich mach den Pepe-Fat-Grip.
Ich hau das einfach bei mir gegen den Bauch.
Hyper-tapping.
Eh, äh, rolling.
Hyper-rolling.
Ich bin immer wieder begeistert.
Ohne Scheiß, ich bin echt immer wieder begeistert,
wie die Leute heute noch bei so alten Games
so Zeugs rausbekommen.
Ja, das typische Ding.
Mit einem Snare, man benutzt den Ricochet von einem Snare,
um es zurückzubringen.
Es gibt viele Weise, viele effizienten Wege,
die Musiker gefunden haben, um viel Bewegung zu bekommen,
ohne die Muskeln zu zerstören.
Aber mit Hyper-tapping ist es so, dass du wirklich
die gleiche Muskel benutzt.
Ja, wenn du es falsch tust,
und du die völkeren Muskeln am Topf deiner Hand benutzt,
kannst du wirklich ein bisschen Schaden machen.
Ich liebe, wie er einfach versucht, den D-Pad zu rollen.
Rob Scound, du warst vor deinem Zeitpunkt.
Das ist eine Sache, mit der ich mich sehr gut anregen kann,
weil ich das Piano spiele und viele Leute sagen,
oh Mann, die schnellste Pianopraktik
hat dich wirklich mit Tetris geholfen.
Und wenn du die selbe Finger wieder und wieder benutzt,
wird es eine schlechte Technik, weil du weniger Kontrolle hast.
Aber wenn du alle Finger zusammen benutzt,
dann sieht diese Bewegung sehr gut aus.
Also, das ist Rollen in der Nutzschau.
Ich dachte, ich muss dieses Video jetzt machen,
weil in der nächsten CTM-Recap...
Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen uns vielleicht heute Abend noch mal.
Oder heute Nachmittag noch mal.
Mal gucken, aber ich muss jetzt erst mal was aufnehmen.
Wir sehen uns, bis dann, macht's gut.
CU.
Muss jetzt mal ganz dringend wohin.
Bis denn.
Bis dahin, dass ihr wieder dabei gewesen seid.